arduino is an open source electronics
platform based on
easy to use hardware and software this
course from ashish will teach you
everything you need to know
to start creating your own electronics
with arduino
and you don't even have to have any
hardware to follow along
hello everyone thank you for joining
this arduino course for beginners
this course is created for people who
have no or very little prior experience
in electronics
and programming so in this course i'm
going to help you get started with your
arduino adventures and by the end of the
course
we will have some basic knowledge of the
most common hardware components
such as breadboard resistor led etc
and their usage in electronic circuits
you will also be able to write arduino
programs on your own
this course is built in such a way that
it would cover
things which absolute beginners face
while understanding the code written by
other creators
while creating this course i've kept in
my mind what problems i had faced
when i started my own journey with
arduino and made it like a course
which i wished i had watched before
starting
anything at all if you don't have an
arduino and other components with you
right now
you can still follow along the course
and get one later
to perform your experiments which you
have in your mind so let's get
started this section will be a quick
overview to practical electronics and
some of the most common electronics
components that we will be using
throughout the course with the arduino
you can always revisit this section if
you find any term confusing or you need
to understand something again
so let us start with electricity i'm
pretty sure that you all must have heard
of this term at least once in your
lifetime
if not let me tell you that electricity
has played a major role in letting you
watch this video on your computer or
your laptop
electricity is a type of energy that can
be built up in one place or flow from
one place to another
when electricity gathers in one place it
is known as static electricity
and electricity when moves from one
place to another
is called current electricity
have you felt a sudden painful jolt when
you brush someone's arm
or crackling sounds when you take off
your sweaters or have you
tried to attract paper bits by a comb
all this happens due to static charges
that were accumulated at a place
believe it or not even the lightning
that happens in the sky
happens due to static electricity so why
does this happen
everything in this universe is made up
of atoms which are made up of protons
and electrons
protons are positively charged and
electrons are negatively charged
in an atom generally the number of
protons and electrons are equal
hence the electric state of atom is
neutral but when some atoms lose their
electrons they become positively charged
and when some atoms gain electrons they
become negatively charged
the short learning which i want you to
take from this lesson
is that similar charges repel and
opposite charges attract each other
as shown in this diagram static
electricity is a very deep topic
and has a separate study called as
electrostatics
which will go beyond the scope of this
course
the other reason i told you about static
electricity is that
the static electric charges in our hands
may damage your electronic components
sometimes
so just make sure you keep your stuff on
hard and solid surfaces
and keep your components back in the
anti-static packets which you got
along with the components current
electricity is the form of electricity
which makes all of our electronic
gadgets work
this form of electricity exists when
charges are able to constantly flow
as opposed to static electricity where
charges gather and remain at rest
current electricity is dynamic charges
are always on the move
we will be focusing on this form of
electricity throughout
the rest of our course so in the next
video we will talk about
voltage which is one of the most
important concepts
for the existence of this current
electricity so i will see you in the
next video
in this video we will learn about
voltage voltage is a force
that makes electrons move through a wire
it is measured in
volts and the symbol is v okay voltage
is also called as
electromotive force or emf which
drives the electrons inside a wire
voltage was named after a scientist
called
alessandro volta so now technically
speaking the voltage is a difference in
electric potential
between two points for example the
difference between
the positive and the negative terminal
of a battery
let's say this battery is of 5 volts so
the potential at this point can be 5
volts and the potential at this point
can be 0 volts
so the potential difference is 5 volts
okay
it can also be 10 volts here and 5 volts
here resulting into a difference of 5
volts it can also be 0 here
and minus 5 here then also the
difference will be
5 volt so this battery provides some
force
on electrons so that they can move
inside a wire
like this you can see these electrons
are moving inside a wire
and and this bulb is glowing now let us
understand
voltage by a water analogy this is a
water tank
and the pressure at the end of the hose
can represent
voltage the water in the tank represents
charge
more the water in the tank the higher is
the charge and
more is the pressure at the end of the
hose we can think of this tank as a
battery
a place where we can store certain
amount of energy and then
release it if we drain our tank a
certain amount the pressure created at
the end of the hose
also goes down right what i mean to say
is we can think of this as a decrease in
voltage like when the flashlights which
use batteries
glow dimmer as the batteries run down
and then there is also a decrease in
amount of water that will flow through
this hose
less pressure means less water is
flowing so we can consider this flowing
water
as current which we will discuss in the
next video
in this video we will learn about
current on a very basic note the rate of
flow of charge is known as current
when electrons move from a negative
terminal to positive terminal of a
battery
they give rise to current the unit of
current is
amperes and the direction in which the
current flows is is the opposite
to the direction of electrons what that
means is
if electrons are moving in this
direction then the current will move in
this direction all right so now on a
more technical note
current is the amount of electric charge
that flows when one coulomb of charge
moves past somewhere in one second and
that current is
one ampere coulomb is the measuring unit
of charge
all right and to measure the current at
any point we can use an ammeter
we can also understand the flow of
current by water analogy
let's say this is a tank filled with
water and this water is flowing due to
potential energy of water which we
learned is called as
voltage in the previous video so here
the size of
hose is acting as resistance a bigger
size hose
offers less resistance and the smaller
size hose offers more resistance
so the path which has
lower resistance more current can flow
through that path
and the path which offers more
resistance less current can
flow through that path okay so here
since the voltage is equal and
resistance is lower in this case
the water flowing here will be more and
the water flowing here will be less
okay so this has given
rise to another term called as
resistance and we will learn about
resistance in
next video but before that i would like
to tell you that there are two types of
current
one is direct current and one is
alternating current in dc current
the flow of electrons stay in the same
direction and the voltage stays
steady with the time as you can see from
the graph
while in ac the flow of electrons change
and the voltage does not stay steady
with time that also you can see from the
graph
don't worry if you could not understand
all this at this moment
at this point you only need to
understand that the current
which you see in your home that is the
current which drives your fans
and other appliances like air
conditioners televisions
etc is known as ac current and the
current which you get from the batteries
or specific power supplies is dc or
direct current the current you get
from your laptop or computer's usb port
is also dc current
and for our course we will be dealing
with the dc current only
if you have understood just this part
you are good to go
so i will see you in the next video now
we will take a look at resistance
the electrical resistance of any
component is a measure of difficulty of
passing an electric current
through that substance with more
resistance in a circuit less electricity
will flow through the circuit
based on this term resistance there is
an electrical component known as a
resistor
a resistor is a device which limits the
flow of a current in a circuit
we may need resistor inner circuits
where we need to drive leds
which require limited amount of current
so that we can prevent it from burning
off
right now if we see the resistance with
the water analogy
we can see this is a pipe and this is
one another pipe
the water can flow easily through this
pipe because it offers less resistance
the flowing water can be
synonymous to flowing current okay and
when there is more resistance
less current will pass through it one
important thing which you would like to
know is
that the current always takes the least
resistive path
for example if you offer two parts for
current to flow
it will try to flow from the least
resistive path out of them
okay so in the next video we will study
the relation between current voltage
and resistance and in upcoming videos we
will also learn
how to identify the value of the
resistor the value
of the resistor is measured in ohms more
the value of resistor
more the resistance it will offer in the
circuit so now i will see you in the
next video
so till now i'm sure that you all must
have inferred that somehow
all these terms are interconnected if
you have then you are absolutely correct
there is a law known as ohm's law which
tells the correlation of these terms
a german physicist george simon ohm
stated
that the electric current flowing
through a metallic wire is directly
proportional
to the potential difference across it
provided
temperature remains the same that means
like i said earlier more the force more
the current
so potential difference is the force
here which we talked about earlier
so mathematically we get voltage v
is equal to the product of resistance r
and
current a or i for that matter
[Music]
if any one of them is unknown we can
find out by doing the math
there's an easy way to find that out
there is a triangle
known as ohm's law triangle
[Music]
we just hide the unknown quantity and we
get
the answer for example if we hide v
so i and r looks in a multiplication
position
so v is equal to i multiplied by r
if we have to find resistance we will
cover up r then v and i
appear in a division like position so r
is equal to v divided by i
then we have i as unknown quantity
then we can do i is equal to v by r
based on the similar reason
this interesting image shows that if we
consider voltage current and resistance
as people
how would they behave the voltage would
keep pushing the current
and resistance would create difficulty
for it to pass
isn't it funny so now let's see how
do we use ohm's law to calculate the
unknown values in a circuit
this is a circuit and this is a very
basic circuit right
and here is the resistance of value 600
ohms
and this is the circuit representation
of a resistance
which is a zigzag line right
here we have a battery which measures 12
volts
and this is the connecting wire so can
you figure out
how much current is flowing in the
circuit right now we will use ohm's law
to find out
okay so here what quantity is unknown
i which is current right so we will be
using i
is equal to v by r so we'll do
12 upon 600 which would be 0.02 amperes
okay so now if we change the value of
our resistance
and make it 6 ohms instead of 600
so can you tell me the new value
we just need to do 12 by 6 now
which would turn out to be 2 amperes all
right
so did you observe that if we reduce the
resistance in a circuit
the current flowing in the circuit
increased earlier it was 0.02 amperes
and now
it is 2 amperes right
now if we change the voltage
of the battery as well let's say 24 so
now the current flowing will be
4 amperes right so we increase the
voltage and reduce the resistance
so the overall current flowing in the
circuit was 4 amperes
so i guess you must be able to see the
relation between voltage
resistance and the current flowing in
the circuit one thing you need to learn
about using resistances in a circuit
is that there are multiple ways we can
use resistances
like we can use them in series we can
use them in parallel
so now i will show you how to use
resistances in series and parallel
if i give you a general idea about
resistances in series in parallel
i would say in a series circuit the
output current of the first resistor
flows into the second resistor and into
the third resistor
therefore the current is the same in
each resistor
while in parallel all the resistors are
connected to each other
in a manner shown here right all the
ends
are connected to each other like this so
now we will look at
series circuit in a bit more detail so
if we look at
the circuit here we can see that three
resistances
r1 r2 and r3 are connected in series
across a battery of a certain voltage
okay we don't know what voltage is that
right now but let's say
that voltage is v right so now since
there is just
one path for current to flow in this
circuit the
value of current flowing in the circuit
would be same let's say
it would be equal to i okay so due to
that
in a series circuit the voltage drop
across each resistor
would be different and interestingly the
sum of v1
v2 and v3 that is the voltage across
each resistor
will be equal to the voltage of the
battery
right let's say if the voltage of the
battery is 12 volts okay
so the voltages which we will get across
these resistances
would add up to 12 and from this circuit
we can create
an equivalent circuit like this where
where the equivalent resistance is the
algebraic sum of
all the resistances which we have used
so let us now see an example
where you can apply this learning right
so here we have a circuit
with five resistances connected in
series
and which are connected across a battery
which measures 9 volts
so what we need to do is we need to find
the equivalent resistance
the current flowing in this circuit and
individual voltages
across each resistance right let's have
our diagram handy with ourself
which we use to remember the ohm's law
so let us first calculate the equivalent
resistance
as i told you to calculate the
equivalent resistance in a series
circuit
we just take the algebraic sum of all
the resistances
right so here
it will be 20 plus 20 plus 20 plus 20
and plus 10 which is equal to 90 ohms
right
now since we have this equivalent
resistance to calculate the current
flowing in the circuit we would use
this formula i is equal to v by r right
the only difference is instead of using
r we will use
r equivalent because we will be using
the equivalent resistance in the circuit
right that would be 9 upon 90 which is
0.1 amperes so now we know
that 0.1 amperes is flowing in this
circuit
so to calculate individual voltages
across the resistances
what we can do we'll use the ohm's law
once again
but this time we will use this formula
we need to calculate v is equal to i
into r
so i is 0.1 and r is 20.
so 0.1 into 20 is 2 volts okay
similarly this will also measure 2 volts
this will also measure 2 volts this will
also measure 2 volts
and this one will be 1 volt because 0.1
into 10
is 1 right so now you notice that
2 plus 2 plus 2 plus 2 and plus 1
is equal to 9 right as we saw earlier as
well
all the voltages also add up to the
voltage of the battery which is 9 volt
all right so this is about series
circuit now we will look at
the parallel circuits so the resistors
are in parallel when one end
of all the resistors are connected by a
continuous wire of negligible resistance
and similarly
other ends are also connected to each
other through a similar wire
since all the resistances in parallel
are connected directly
to the battery you can say the voltage
across all of them
is equal right but unlike the resistors
in series
where there is just one path for current
to flow in parallel circuits
there are multiple paths for resistance
to flow like in the circuit you can see
current has two parts if the current
flowing in the circuit is i
then it will divide into two parts let's
say i1 and i2
if there were more resistances we would
say like i3 and i4 etc
and when that current flows it comes
back and
it adds up and becomes i again and if we
wish to calculate the values of i1 and
i2
again we can use the ohm's law here
right because the voltage
across this resistors is equal to the
battery's voltage
and the value of resistor is also known
so we can calculate i using ohm's law
right
you should remember that v1 and v2 will
always be equal to
v and i will be equal to
i1 plus i2 right
now we can also calculate the equivalent
resistance
this combination of resistors will offer
in the circuit
and to do that there is a very simple
formula
one upon req that is equivalent
resistance is equal to
1 by r1 plus 1 by r2 plus 1 by r3
and so on right so let us see one
example
and let us keep that diagram handy again
right so what we need to do in this
question is
we need to find out the current flowing
in this circuit
and the individual current flowing in
these resistances
right so one approach can be we can find
out the equivalent resistance first
using the formula we just saw let us
place the values inside it
right 1 by req is equal to 1 by 1
plus 1 by 2 plus 1 by 2.
we have just replaced these values by
the values of the resistors
right so now we will take lcm
and which turns out to be 4 by 2
but please note that this is 1 by r
equivalent
all right so to calculate r equivalent
we will take the reciprocal of this
value which would turn out to be
0.5 ohms right so now we have
the equivalent resistance of this
circuit we can simply use
the formula i is equal to v by r v is 3
and r is 0.5
so the answer would be 6 amperes right
so 6 amperes will be flowing in this
circuit
now if we want to calculate the
individual currents in these
resistances what we will do is we will
use
this formula again because v is same
and r is known right so in this resistor
v is three and r is one so in this
resistor three amperes will be flowing
in this resistor
three by two that means one point five
would be flowing right and in this
resistance as well
1.5 amperes would be flowing so now if
we add up
all these currents in these three
resistances
that would come out to be six so again
we verified the things we just studied
and i don't know if you noticed or not
the equivalent resistance
of 0.5 was even lesser than the lowest
of the resistance is used
right so this will always be the case
the equivalent resistances
in the parallel circuits will always
come out to be
lesser than the lowest value of the
resistance in those combinations
all right so this was about parallel
circuits
and now we will see a slightly more
complicated circuit
which involves series and parallel
circuits both
so here we have such a circuit where
resistances
are present in series as well and panel
as well
so now i will tell you how to find out
unknown values
in such kind of circuits right so first
of all
we need to work in sections of the
circuit for example
in this circuit i have taken up this
section we can see that these two
resistances
r3 and r4 are in series right so using
our regular
resistances in series formula which is r
equivalent is equal to r1 plus r2 plus
r3 and so on
right so here are two resistances so we
have just taken some of those two
resistances
which is 10 ohm then in our mind we will
think of it as
one single resistor right which is in
parallel with
this resistance right so now we will use
our parallel formula
which is 1 by r equivalent is equal to 1
by
r1 plus 1 by r2 right
so both of the resistances are of 10
ohms so if you plug the values
in this formula you will get 5 ohms you
can try it on your own right
then we will reduce that circuit in our
mind only
with 5 ohms as a resistance then this
equivalent resistance
is in series with 7 ohm resistor right
again we will use our resistance in
series formula
so the equivalent resistance will turn
out to be 12 ohms
so now let's have our ohm's law formula
handy
right so what we can find out now is how
much current is flowing in this circuit
how we can do that we will use this
formula i is equal to v by
r where v is 24 and r is
12 so we will get 2 amperes
right so now if we want to know voltages
across
each resistance and current flowing in
each resistance
we can work our way backwards now right
so we know two amperes is flowing in
this circuit so we can calculate the
voltages across
these two resistances right so first we
will calculate
across 7 ohm resistor so how will we do
that we'll use v is equal to
i into r i is 2 and r is 7
so we will get 14 volts across this
okay and here we will get
2 into 5 10 volts right so you can see
14 plus 10 is 24 we are satisfying the
things which we have studied so far
now we'll move one step back so we knew
voltage across this resistance
was 10 volts right so in this section
also
the voltage will be 10 volts so now
since this is a parallel circuit in both
of the resistances
voltage will be 10 volts so now we can
calculate
current in this right by using this
formula again
right v is 10 and r is also 10
so 1 ampere would be flowing inside it
the answer would be same for this one as
well
right now if we take one step back again
we'll have to calculate voltage across
these two resistances how will we do
that again we'll use this formula
v is equal to i into r so current was 1
ampere in this
so in this as well it will be 1 ampere
so we know
6 into 1 is 6 volts
and across this one we'll have 4 volts
using the same formula right so we have
all the unknown values
right now since there were so many
values i can understand it must be a
little difficult for some of you to
visualize it
so i have created a circuit to help you
visualize a little
right let's have a look at it so here is
that visualization
so you can see exactly similar circuit
which we saw earlier
and i have written all the values of
current flowing in each resistance
and now i will show you the voltages
across each resistance
let's keep this formula handy as always
now i will show you voltage across each
resistance
it is 14 volts across 7 ohms 6 volts
across 6 ohms
4 volts across 4 ohms and 10 volts
across
10 ohms right so if you have understood
this part
i can say you have understood really
important fundamental
about using resistances in series and
parallel but
you may also find circuits like this
okay
where we have two batteries right in
circuits like these
you cannot simplify the circuits which
we have seen so far
so there are some advanced concepts such
as kirchhoff's law
okay which is used to calculate the
unknown values in the circuit
but that will go beyond the scope of our
course right now so one last thing about
resistances i want to tell you is
identifying the resistance is based on
the color bands
let's have a look at that now
resistances
come with the four or five color bands
denoting the value of resistance
it will offer in the circuit
so you see in this diagram there are
four band
resistors and there are five band
resistors
okay in a four band register the first
band will tell you the first digit
the second band will tell you the second
digit
the third band will tell you the number
of zeros which you need to put after the
first two digits
and the fourth band tells the error
percentage
means it can be that much percentage
above or below
the stated value now see the first band
in this case
is yellow so it the first digit will be
four the second band is violet so the
second digit will be
seven the third band is origin color
so the multiplier will be one thousand
so we get the value of
forty seven thousand and the fourth band
is
gold so that means it will have a
tolerance of plus minus
five percent so the net value of this
resistance is
47 000 ohms
or you can say 47 kilo ohms with the
tolerance of five percent
now we see the five band code okay
the first band tells the first digit the
second man tells you the second digit
the third bank tells you the third digit
fourth band tells you the multiplier
here
and first bank tells you the tolerance
we'll consider this example
first band is orange and color so the
first digit will be three
second band is green so the value will
be
five the third band is black in color
so the third value will be zero
and fourth band is red so the multiplier
will be
hundred till now we get three five zero
and double zero so this is 35 000
and the last band is brown in color so
one percent of tolerance so the net
answer will be
35 kilo ohms with a tolerance of one
percent
you can refer to this chart whenever you
need to find the value of your
resistances
and i understand this might be confusing
at first but with practice
you can understand this very easily in
this section
we will finally take a look at the main
thing most of you must be already
waiting for this section to come up
so this blue colored thing which is
present in your kit is the arduino board
i will tell you what is it what it can
do
and how to start using it finally
but before that i would like to tell you
about some terms which you may
or may not have heard about before
starting this course
so these terms are microprocessor
microcontroller
memory integrated circuits etc
microprocessors are known as a brain of
any computer
they consist of a cpu which stands for
central processing unit
which is responsible for doing all the
computations and calculations which we
need to carry out
they need additional peripherals like
ram and rom in order to function
example of a microprocessor is the cpu
which is being used in your computer
right now
if you go and check the history of
microprocessors you will see the
microprocessors have come a long way
after so many improvements in
developments microprocessors
and graphic processors are used where
there is a need of heavy computational
cycles
like artificial intelligence deep
learning self-driving cars
and high-end robots our daily
applications like playing games
movies browsing internet also requires
our microprocessors
and then there are microcontrollers
microcontrollers are integrated chips
that are basically tiny computers but
are powerful enough to do a lot many
tasks
like controlling motors pumps other
appliances or they can send some sensor
data to internet cloud
control basic displays and even act as
brains of some intermediate level robots
applications are endless trust me the
power requirements of such integrated
chips is very low
and you can even run these chips on
batteries
for days or even months they have all
the peripherals like memory and flash
storage
built on the same chip
[Music]
if we compare microcontroller and
microprocessor
in terms of cost a microcontroller is
far cheaper than a microprocessor
however
microcontroller cannot be used in place
of a microprocessor
and using a microprocessor is not
advised in place of a microcontroller
as it makes the application quite costly
if we compare them in terms of speed if
we say human brain is fast
then microcontroller is faster and
microprocessor is fastest
but please note we are talking in a very
general way this won't be applicable if
you compare an old generation thing with
a new generation thing
as technology advances it won't make any
sense to compare
and also some exceptions are always
there it is really possible that you
or any human may be faster
[Music]
so do you have any guesses in which
category or arduino board will fall
if you said microcontroller then you are
partially right
an absolutely correct answer is that
arduino is a circuit board
which has a microcontroller on it which
act as the heart of that board
the arduino board given to you in your
kit is arduino uno
which uses microcontroller atmega328
there are many more kinds of arduino
boards available with other
microcontrollers
which may be superior or inferior to
atmega328
but arduino uno is just right for our
applications
you may want to pause the video here to
have a look at all these
boards and admire how beautifully they
are made
so arduino is basically a company in
italy which made it really easy for
people to use microcontrollers for their
application
the hardware and software of arduino is
open source which means
one can have access to the files and
even modify them for their own work
since it is open source many other
companies take their design and
manufacture their own versions of
arduino
so it is really easy to clone and modify
the arduino board
[Music]
what makes arduino a beginner-friendly
tool is their easy to use
hardware and software it can be used
even by people
having no technical background
earlier people would have to use very
difficult assembly language to control
their votes
but it is not the case with arduino
as you progress with the course you will
see yourself with how easy and intuitive
this tool is
you will see that uploading the code is
as simple as plugging a usb cable and
clicking upload button
in this video we will see the parts
which make up the arduino board
so this is the diagram of arduino board
which shows the typical components which
are placed on it
so we will begin by the digital pins the
pins which you see
here which are numbered 0 to 13
and some pins have a special symbol like
this
curvy symbol on in front of it which
denotes pwm capability
that means these pins support pwm other
than that
these pins take digital input from
sensors and give digital output
to some of the components all right so
then we move to the built-in led
which is shown by this led
this led by default is connected to pin
number 13. so whenever pin number 13
goes high
this led will turn on and when that pin
goes low
this led will turn off and then
we will see the power led this is the
power led
if this led is turned on that means your
arduino is plugged in
that means it's turned on right now then
we have
the main component the atmega328 chip
it controls all the main functions of
this board
whatever is happening on this board is
due to
this ship then we have
analog pins we have six analog pins on
this board
numbered from a0 to a5
we can connect any analog sensor on
these pins
then we have the power pins these are
the power pins
you can power any component using these
pins but make sure that you don't your
components are not drawing a lot of
current
basic sensors and basic you know
breadboard circuits
are fine with these pins
then we see the power dc jack if you
want to connect
your arduino externally through a dc
jack you can connect it
through this jack the voltage input it
can accept is 7 volts to
12 volts then we have tx and rx leds
these are the tx and rx leds rx means
receive tx means send
transmit okay so whenever these leds are
blinking that means
cardinal board is either communicating
with the computer
or some other another arduino board
then we have the usb jack you connect
your arduino board with your computer
using this jack
then we have the reset button this
button reloads the entire code which is
running on the
arduino board but please note that this
button does not
clears the memory of arduino
here are few technical specifications of
arduino uno
by technical specifications i mean the
information which you look
while buying any item or a computer like
in a computer you see how much disk
space is there
how much ram does it have or processor
it has similarly
arduino being a microcontroller board
has some technical specifications
like it has atmega328 as the main chip
which does all the work it operates at 5
volts
the input voltage which it can accept is
5 to 12 volts
although according to the data sheet of
arduino
the recommended voltage is 7 to 12 volts
and the limits
are 6 to 20 volts so i recommend that
5 to 12 volts is a good enough voltage
to operate
arduino with and then there are
14 digital pins out of which six are pwm
capable
don't worry about pwm right now but just
think having pwm capability is a good
thing
then there are six analog pins which are
used to connect analog sensors to the
arduino
you can understand that these pins are
connected to arduino
through a 10 bit adc an adc is
an analog to digital converter we'll
talk about adc
in further lectures
the i o pins are capable of supplying 40
milliamperes of current
so these pins cannot drive large
appliances or the things which require
more current like motors and it is not
even recommended
that you run motors through arduino but
few leds and most sensors which we use
in this course do not draw very large
amount of current
so these pins are just fine
there is a 3.3 volt pin as well and the
maximum current you can draw from it is
50 milliamperes
and there is a flash memory of 32 kb
which we use
to store all the programs into it 32 kb
must be seeming like a very less amount
but trust me you can store lines
of 1000 even 2000 lines of code in this
and it won't even exceed 10 percent of
the storage
then it have sram of 2kb which is a
volatile memory
or more generally it is similar to ram
on your computer
again it would seem too less and i would
repeat
what i said for the flash memory that it
is more than enough
it also has 1 kb of eep rom which can
store
some variables even after you switch off
the arduino
clock speed is 16 megahertz clock speed
is the speed that microprocessor
executes each instruction
one megahertz representing one million
cycles per second
i understand a lot of information in
this video might have just bounced over
your head
and it's perfectly okay if you don't
understand some portion of it
i would just say don't lose your
motivation and just stick with us
and i promise you you will understand
each and every part
of it by the end of the course if not we
are always here for help
in this section i will tell you about
arduino ide
but before we jump into that first of
all we need to understand what an ide
is a text editor like a notepad
along with the compiler is a bare
minimum requirement to start
coding but wait what is a compiler
compiler is a special program that
processes statements written in a
programming language
and turns them into a machine language
which are basically zeros and ones which
a computer can understand
but unlike text editor an ide which
stands for integrated development
environment
is a software tool which has a lot more
functionality to make programming easier
for the user
it has a built-in text editor and
compiler along with easy to use tools
menus and buttons to compile
run debug analyze
and save the programs
considering arduino they also have one
official ide
which has buttons to verify and upload
the sketches they also have
easy to use menus to select boards and
ports
throughout the course we will be using
the official arduino ide
and for that in the following sections
we will be downloading
and installing the official arduino ide
now i will tell you how to install the
official ide
for that go to any browser and go to
arduino dot cc then click on software
tab
you will find many options here we will
go with the windows installer
click on just download if you don't wish
to donate anything
donations like these help open source
communities to fund themselves
once the download completes
we will click on it and when the
installation starts
click on i agree make sure that all
these boxes
are checked these are the essential
drivers which are required
for your computer to detect and
communicate with the
arduino board right we'll click on next
then we will choose the destination
folder i will go with the default one
and click on install
this process may take some time let's
wait for it
to finish
in my screen it says completed but some
people may get additional prompts to
install those additional drivers
all you need to do is just click on
install on them as well
and then once it is completed for you
click on close and then you will find
the arduino icon
on your desktop then you just double
click on it
and here is your fully functional
arduino ide
window so now we will set up our
computer for uploading our first basic
sketch
there is nothing complicated we need to
do the first step is
we need to plug in an arduino board with
the usb cable given
in the box and once you do that your
computer will automatically detect that
arduino has been plugged in
and it will list it out on a specific
serial port
in windows it is known as a com port
which you need to go
and select using tools go to tools and
then go to port
and you will automatically see a com
port here
it is very likely that you see com3 if
you have plugged your arduino for the
very first time
okay so you will see arduino genuine
uno written over here if you're using
mac
then you will see something like this
forward slash dev
dot forward slash cu dot usb modem this
is the port number
and you will see arduino uno here
instead of adding omega i have tested
with arduino mega that's why it is
showing it
like that but you will see arduino uno
right
if you're using linux you will see
serial port as
power slash dev tty acm0 it is most
likely will find it at
at acm 0. after this step
we are just ready to upload our first
basic sketch
so finally we will be testing our
arduino boards and for that we will be
using the built-in example sketches
so in order to upload our first sketch
we'll go to examples we'll go to basics
and then we'll select the blink sketch
this is the first sketch which will be
uploading
on our arduino board we'll go to tools
we'll select our board as arduino uno
and we'll select
our port as com3 and
then we will go to upload button we'll
click on upload in order to upload the
code
there are more buttons like verify save
open we will talk about these buttons
in upcoming sections but now we'll click
on upload
it will first compile the sketch and
then it will upload the code to the
board
after uploading you will see done
uploading will appear
in the messages done uploading right
and you will see that led is blinking
with this gap of one second
is it blinking right if it is blinking
then congratulations you have done your
first example
at this point the viewers without an
arduino must be feeling a little stuck
but please don't worry i've got you
covered all you need to do
is use an online simulator like
autodesk tinkercad and for that you need
to go to
the website of tinkercad
right this one
and you need to create an account if you
don't have it already
you can choose the option relevant to
you make an account
and after creating your account you will
see a screen like this
all you need to do is click on circuits
and create a new circuit
at this window we need to search
arduino uno r3
and just drag it over here
right so now you have your virtual
arduino board
it will just function exactly like the
actual arduino board
and whatever code i write in official id
in the following videos
you need to write that into this window
right so you will have this window over
here
whatever code i am writing in the
official id you just need to
write that in this area okay so just as
you saw
few moments ago that we tested our
arduino board
so we will now test our arduino board
over here
right so this is the same code which we
wrote over there
only the comments are not here right so
this is exactly the same code
and what we need to do after that is
start simulation
okay so it will be plugged in and
you know we can see the outcome of our
code over here
and in some portions of the video you
will also see that i am
printing out the outputs of some code on
the serial monitor
so the serial monitor in this simulator
is this
right so you will see whatever outputs
i'm showing in the videos you can see
them here
okay so don't worry if you don't have an
arduino at this point you can still
follow along the video so before we move
forward from this point
having the knowledge of a few more
things would be greatly beneficial
things such as breadboard how to make
connections in breadboard
some safety instructions for the arduino
and
some basic terms like input output
sensors analog
digital bit and byte you may want to
revisit this section as well
if you find yourself forgetting about
these concepts as we proceed
all right so let's start with breadboard
is this the first thought which came to
your mind when you heard of breadboard
well that's a perfectly genuine thought
when i stepped in the field of
electronics i myself had this thought
but when i learned that the breadboard
in electronics is a completely different
thing
i had a really big face pump moment
let's discuss this in the comment
section as to why it is called as
breadboard
or from where it got its name we will
just talk
about breadboard in terms of electronics
breadboards are meant to make quick
non-permanent connections between
electronic components
and they are covered with tiny socket
holes which are
connected in rows the breadboard
itself is broken into four sections
there are two inner sections full of
short horizontal rows
and two outer sections with long
vertical rows
if we remove the adhesive which is
present on the back side of the
breadboard we would see
something like this a series of
metal connections do you see that
we'll discuss what this means in a few
moments
but before that i would like to show you
the strip which is connected inside that
it is a single strip which is taken out
from that bright board and it would look
like that
so you see this entire metal piece
so when we make connections on that
you know it is internally connected
automatically
coming back to this if we consider
this row corresponds to this
all right so that means these points
are connected among themselves
automatically
and like these rails are connected
so these points are also connected from
inside
we'll discuss this in detail we'll also
make circuits don't worry about that
if you're wondering what kind of
circuits which we can make on a
breadboard
i would like to tell you that you can
also make your arduino uno
on the breadboard and it would look like
this now we will see
how to use a breadboard we will also
understand the connections
in details all right
so this is our breadboard okay can you
see
all these holes like this
which are getting highlighted in blue
right these are the holes
which i was talking about in the
previous video
okay so i'll now show you how they are
interconnected for example
these points are interconnected the
yellow ones all of these are
interconnected
within themselves right like these all
these points
are connected among themselves but
please note
that this point is not connected to this
point internally
this point is only connected to these
points like can you see
right like this all these points are
interconnected
all right so then we'll see these points
these are the external points all of
these points are interconnected
like this right
like this and like this in some
breadboards there are connection break
at this point so you will just see
that the points are connected only till
here
and these points are connected till here
but this point is not connected to this
point
in some breadboards but in most
breadboards they are all connected
like this can you see that okay
so now i'll tell you if you want to
connect
some two points for example we'll take a
wire
and we'll join this so now
these points are connected among
themselves right
no matter how many wires we join here
these will still stay connected okay
and what if i connect a wire here
then all these points will get connected
you see that
right i think it is really interesting
to see that how easy
it makes for us to make connections on
the breadboard
right so now we'll see how to make a
series connection
right we'll take a resistance
like this okay and we'll place it here
okay now i will take another resistance
and connect it here okay
so now these resistances are in series
now if i make want to make another
resistance which i want to take in
series
i'll place them here
all right now these three resistance are
connected in series
how for example these points were
interconnected
okay and so we connected our resistance
here so that means they are in
a continuous position now similarly
here as well okay i would like to tell
you that some people
make a mistake and to make a series
connection they would go like this
they will place the resistance here
instead of placing it here
right this is a series connection but
this is
no connection at all because these
points are not interconnected
however if we join a wire like this
okay so now these points are
interconnected
okay i hope i am making you myself clear
now we will try to understand a parallel
connection
similarly we'll take resistance
and we'll place it here now since
in parallel connections all of the
points are you know
originating and ending at the same point
and these points are interconnected
so we'll take another resistance and
place it here
so these two resistance are in parallel
now if you want to
take a third resistance as well and
we'll take it and place it here now
these three resistances are
in parallel okay now we want to make a
connection
in which there is a resistance in series
and then there are two resistances in
parallel
we'll try to make that circuit
this is one resistance okay and then
if we make it like this
like this
okay and we take another resistance
and we place it like this okay so what
that is representing
it is one resistance which is in series
with this resistances which are in
parallel among themselves
and then there's another resistance
which is in series with that
okay okay it's all right if you don't
understand what i'm trying to say right
now
we'll understand this with one more
example
so before i begin with my second example
i would like to tell you
a few more things like i told you
in the previous video if we connect a
wire like this
the points become interconnected
but if you take a resistance and connect
it like this
[Music]
so these points are not connected to
these points right because it is a
resistance
you see that in this case these points
are interconnected
but in the case of resistance these
points are not interconnected
now another point which i want you to
notice every connected wire
like this it won't make any sense
as these points are already
interconnected right
so this wire will not make any
difference
so now another thing which i want you to
notice
if we take a resistance and if we place
it like
[Music]
this
like this then also
it won't make any difference because as
we all know the current always takes the
least resistive path
so connecting a resistance like this
won't make any difference because the
current will travel
through the rails only this resistance
will not add any value to the circuit
okay but however if you connect a
resistance like this
then it would make some sense okay how
it will make some sense we will see
[Music]
for example we can connect it like this
and like this
okay so this is a series connection now
these two resistances are in series
but yeah please note that these
resistances
[Music]
are not in parallel
but please note that these resistances
because these points are not connected
okay
now we will begin with our second
example in this example
we will just connect an led with a push
button and a battery
okay so when we press the push button
that led will
blow so we will make a circuit on that
so for that we'll take a push button
circuit first of all
okay this is a push button circuit i'll
tell you about push button circuit
that internally this terminal is
connected to this terminal
okay so automatically this rail will get
connected to this rail
okay like this
and this terminal is connected to this
terminal so these points will also get
interconnected
okay so when you press this button
this terminal gets connected to this
terminal
okay so these points will get connected
when you press
the switch all right then we will take a
battery
let's take this battery this is a simple
battery 3.7 volts
let's place it here this has a positive
terminal and a negative terminal
we'll try to connect it on a rail
let's make this wire as red color
[Music]
and the black wire as
the black one okay in general
electronics
this is also a convention that the red
wire represents positive terminal and
the
black wire represents the negative
terminal okay so now
these and this entire rail okay so now
this entire rail
is positive okay as we have connected
the positive terminal of the battery
here just see that
and this terminal is negative this
entire rail is negative
okay so we will start by placing a
resistor
as we should always connect our
resistance in series
when using a led
replace it like this okay
so that means this point and this point
are interconnected so this resistance is
in series with this switch
and then we'll take one led
this is the led okay
as we all know there is a positive end
and the negative end
of the led so this is the positive end
and this is the negative end we have
connected the negative end to the
resistance
okay to make the led glow we have to
always connect the positive end
of the led to the positive end of the
battery
okay so first of all what we'll do is
we'll take a positive wire
from here right as we know all know this
entire rail is positive
so from any point on this rail we can
take
positive line so we'll take a positive
line from here
and connect it here
this is a general wire so we'll make it
blue all right
and then what we want is we need to
complete the circuit like this
we'll take a black wire from here and
connect it here
okay so this is our circuit
completed whenever we press this switch
this circuit will get completed the
positive
wire will go from here the current will
flow from positive terminal like this
it will flow from resistance and it will
go from circuit and then
to the negative end and back to the
battery
but whenever we release the switch the
circuit will break and the led will stop
glowing
this was the very basic example of a led
in a
breadboard in this video we will discuss
about
some of the safety instructions which we
need to follow while using our arduino
board
the first thing which you need to keep
in your mind is you never have to
connect
any voltage of over 5 volts on any i o
pin
okay any i o pin means any input output
be it the digital pins or the analog
pins you just don't have to connect any
voltage over 5 volts on those pins you
can only use
any voltage over 5 volts to power the
arduino
through v in pin and you cannot connect
any pin
to a voltage over 5 volts okay
next important thing you need to notice
you never have to connect
a 5 volt pin to a ground pin this way
you will short it down
an arduino will turn off the next point
is you have to take care of the polarity
polarity means you cannot connect
positive and negative terminals in
opposite ways what i mean is you cannot
connect a positive pin
to a negative pin of some other
component and vice versa if there is no
polarity management circuit on the
device which you are using it will
simply damage the device one more point
is you have to be careful while using
external power in this course for all
the project the usb power
would be more than enough but still if
you need any external power
you can use it through dc jack or vn
pins
and in that case also please make sure
you don't connect any voltage above 12
volts
although arduino can tolerate up to 20
volts but still
it i advise you that don't use above 12
volts otherwise you will see
unnecessary heating on the arduino board
okay
so these were the main safety
instructions which you need to follow
or you may damage your arduino and while
doing our experiments
i will also tell you about more safety
instructions if they are required
okay so now i will see you in the next
video in this video
i will talk about input and output and
how to understand it with respect to
arduino you may want to revisit this
video when we study pin mode function
it has been taught in arduino
programming section so generally
speaking
input is something which goes inside
an output is something which comes
outside
speaking technically input is some data
or signal which goes into the system
an output is some process information or
signal which comes out of that system
the system may be anything like in our
case the system would mostly be arduino
the sensors would be giving the data to
the arduino an arduino would act on that
data
and give an output based on how you have
programmed it
please bear in mind that input and
output is never absolute
it is always relative to something as
you may have been told in junior classes
that input and output devices are fixed
yes they are fixed but with the
reference to the computer
like a mouse is an input device to the
computer but if we look in the mouse
itself
there would be several more devices like
an optical reader
which takes the movement of the mouse as
input and gives its output
to the chip inside which processes it
and gives the cursor position as output
similarly we have been told that a
printer is an output device
yes it is certainly an output device but
with reference to the computer
now if we see in a printer as well there
is a main controller board which takes
the input signal which is coming out
from the computer and then that
controller takes the decision
that how to move the motors which colors
to select
in order to print the page i hope i am
making some sense to you
now if we see in reference to our course
there are lot many things
and sensors which act as input devices
for the arduino
like these sensors which you can see on
the screen but wait what are sensors
like humans have five senses which help
us get aware of our surroundings and act
accordingly
similarly in electronics sensors help
the controller to take decisions
and give output based on the
environmental data which is given by
them
sensors tell something to the controller
by changing its voltage
a change in voltage is read by the
controller like we see in this image
there is an autonomous car which has n
number of sensors placed on it which are
telling it about the other cars
battery level fuel level humidity level
etc
now i will briefly discuss about these
sensors which you see on the screen
we will also discuss these sensors in
detail when we use these particular
sensors first of all we see is a
rotatory potentiometer
this device would change the resistance
it offers if we rotate the knob
clockwise or anti-clockwise
then we have a momentary push button
switch when we press the switch it will
close the circuit when we
release the switch it will open the
circuit then we have a force sensing
resistor
this resistor changes its resistance
based on the force applied on it
then we have a light dependent resistor
this resistance change its resistance
based on the light falling on it then we
have a triple axis accelerometer
usually we see accelerometers in phones
and gaming devices
okay the basic purpose of the
accelerometer is to get the orientation
of the object
on which it is placed then we have a
joystick
joystick is nothing but a basic input
controller you must have seen it on
on the gaming consoles then we have a
microphone or a sound sensor
it will capture the environmental sound
and noises
we may want to record them or take some
decisions based on that
then we have a touch sensor it will just
see if someone is touching it or not
then we have a rotary encoder
this sensor senses the rotation
basically for example
you can attach this rotary encoder to a
motor shaft and we can see the
rotational speed of that motor
how many rotations it have taken or you
must have seen a rotary encoder in
our volume knobs in your music systems
and we have an ultrasonic distance
sensor
it uses ultrasonic waves like in a sonar
to tell the distance between
the sensor and the object in front of it
then we have a temperature sensor as the
name suggests it will tell the
temperature around it
we have a temperature and humidity
sensor it tells humidity as well along
with the temperature
then we have an infrared sensor this is
basically an obstacle detection sensor
it can tell if an object is there in
front of it or not
then we also have output devices
output devices are those devices that
can convert the output
given by the arduino to some human
readable form
right for example i'll tell you there is
an led which is known as light emitting
diode it will basically
just glow if any pin on arduino is set
to high
and we have an rgb led this is a special
led
it has all the colors uh red green and
blue leds and it can form
n number of colors and we have a buzzer
it will make some sound
if high voltage is given to it it will
make some sound then we have a
loudspeaker
like this general speaker which you have
seen in your mobiles and your laptops
which you know
you play music through and we have an
oled display
it is a full-fledged display you can
just click graphics on it we have lcd
display this is liquid crystal display
you can
display characters on it okay for
example some value of a sensor or
someone's name
etc the seven segment display consists
of seven leds
arranged in a rectangular fashion as
shown
it is used to display numbers on it
for example if we want to display seven
so we will highlight this one this one
and this one
so we will see that seven is appearing
if we want to show zero
then we will highlight these ones
okay and if you want to display eight we
will highlight all of them and it will
look like it is coming on we have a dot
matrix display dot matrix display is an
array of multiple leds okay we can show
even characters on it
you must have seen a dot matrix display
in delhi mid to display
or even you know scrolling displays you
must have seen in front of some shops
which display the shop's name so that is
a dot matrix display then we have a dc
motor it basically
moves clockwise or anti-clockwise if it
is given some voltage across it then we
have servo motor so
this is a special kind of motor we can
stop it at specific angles then we have
a stepper motor a stepper motor is just
like a dc motor
but you know the entire rotation is
divided into equal steps
so like servo motor we can also stop it
at specific angles and
even lift heavier loads we can drive
heavier loads using a stepper motor so
to conclude this video i would like to
say
since we know about input and output
properly now we can easily understand
how arduino interacts with the
environment and we can make some
meaningful projects after knowing this
see you in the next video in this video
we will talk about analog and digital so
to begin with
i would like to tell you that our world
is full of analog information
like the colors we see fragrances we
smell flavors we taste
sounds we hear temperature we feel all
these
have just endless number of values there
can be millions of colors
smells flavors sounds etc this was in a
very general sense
now if we see in the terms of
electronics something which is analog
can have infinite number of values let's
say your wall clock
it can show endless number of time
intervals though
they are not marked on it but yet it
holds the capability
to tell you even smaller fractions of
time while digital is something
with discrete or limited number of
values like a digital clock
that clock can show you limited number
of digits let's say it's 2 pm
or 10 minutes past 2 pm depending on the
precision of that clock
it may still show you seconds but it is
still limited to
some values only so before we move
further we also need to understand one
more term
called as signal signals are used to
convey some information to someone
like these road signs are passing on
some information to us
like that we need to stop or we cannot
park here etc
similarly when we speak we generate a
signal and that signal contains the
information which we want to pass on to
the listener
like i'm speaking right now i'm
generating an audio signal which you can
see on this screen
this is the audio signal which i have
generated with my
voice okay
so this signal passes through my mouth
through air and to your ear
and you make some sense out of it okay
this audio signal is analog in nature
because there are infinite number of
values which are changing
okay in electronics signals are some
time varying quantities which convey
some sort of information
usually that time varying quantity is
voltage
that means with time the voltage changes
okay or sometimes it is also current
but usually it is voltage then those
time varying signals are passed between
the devices in order to send and receive
information
which might be video audio or some sort
of encoded data
usually signals are transmitted through
wires but they can also be passed
through
air wirelessly okay so there is an
entire field of study
which is based just on signals like
digital signal processing
signals and systems there are some
entire subjects based on signals only
okay but for the scope of this course we
will just tell you the required
information
so now there are two types of signals
one is analog signal and one is
digital signal like we just saw that our
sound is a type of analog signal
similarly there can be other analog
signals as well
typically an analog signal would look
like this that means we have plotted
time on the x-axis and voltage on the
y-axis so with time
the voltage is increasing then
decreasing then going into negative part
then increasing this is an analog signal
it is not necessary that it stays
this smooth it can be little messy as
well
like this this is also an analog signal
okay and then there is a digital signal
in digital signals
there are only two discrete values
either it is on or either it is
off where 5 volts represents on and 0
volts represent off so you can see
with time here it is on it is off on off
on
off on and off right now the sensors
and the sensors which we use in our
course will either give
analog signal or either digital signal
and we have to use arduino to read
those signals okay we will see an
example
let's say we have a gaming console here
this is the joystick
this is a device which would give some
analog signal
and these are the buttons and these
devices will give some digital
information so this game machine can be
programmed to read this
state of the joystick for example we can
make a character move
forward when the joystick is moved
forward we can also control the moving
speed of that character for example
if we make the joystick move a little
forward then it will move slow
and if we move it a little more ahead
then it will move faster
but this cannot be the case with the
digital button we can just press the
switch
and tell the character to move forward
we cannot decide the speed we can only
set
one speed there or we can program it to
move forward
fast based on some time okay but we
cannot input
the speed through buttons right so this
joystick is sending some
analog signal into the computer or the
controller which is placed inside this
gaming machine and these buttons
are sending some digital information
like either they are pressed or not
they are on or off okay but this is a
digital signal
i'll give you one more example we have
potentiometer here
and we can move it as a knob
and we have infinite number of values
here we have a switch which is either on
or off
this represents analog and this
represents digital
so whenever we use analog sensor or
component we will use
analog pins of the arduino and we use
digital pins
for digital sensors or components okay i
have given more insights on this topic
in analog read and digital read video in
programming section once you reach there
and watch those videos as well
it will be crystal clear to you and if
not you can just comment down below or
send us a message
in this video we will talk about bit and
buy so basically what is
bit bit is the smallest storage or
memory size which can store a value of
either zero
or either one this box represents a bit
here
okay similarly if eight bits are
combined then it forms
a byte okay so we can say eight bits is
equal to
one byte so one byte can store zero
as the smallest number why because in
that case
all the eight boxes or all the eight
bits
are holding zero inside it as i told you
it can either store zero
or one okay so each box
has a multiplier and we take the value
from this box
and we multiply it with this box okay
and calculate the value here and in the
end we take sum of
all the values so here what will happen
0 multiplied by 2 to the power
0 2 to the power 0 is 1 0 into 0 is 0
0 into this is 0 0 into anything is 0
similarly in all the boxes
we'll get 0 so hence the smallest value
will be
0 and when will be the maximum value
if all the boxes are 1 right so here we
will get
1 into 2 to the power 0 that is 1
and 2 to the power 1 is 2 here we'll get
here we will get 4 here we will get 8
here it will be
16 here it will be 32 64 and 128
now if you take a sum of all these value
you can calculate it on your own we will
get
255. now in case if we want to store a
value greater than 255
so now in that case we will have to take
one more bit
aside this so it will become 9 bit
so the 9 bits can store 511 values
and what if we have to store a bigger
number than that then we will add
another bit here as well and it will
become 10 bits so 10 bits will be able
to store
a value till 1 0 2 3. so now what you
have to keep in mind is
you will be needing this information
whenever i say 8 bits 10 bits 12 bits in
the course
so we can only store values up to the
upper limit of that space
okay so this information will be
sufficient for you to carry on the
course
but yeah if you want to know more about
binary math you can just google
binary maths and you will get really
good links from wikipedia and other
websites
and you can just read them if you face
any problem you can always comment down
below
and we will get back to you in this
section i would cover all the essential
programming concepts that you would need
to get working and make projects with
arduino i would like to tell you that
programming is a game of practice
the more you practice the more you get
better at that so i would cover all the
essential topics to get you started and
i will also tell you about concepts as
we progress ahead
so let's get started before we know
about arduino programming we need to
understand what programming is
programming is something which we do to
tell a computer or a controller what to
do
computers don't understand the language
which humans use to communicate with
each other
computers only understand the zeros and
ones so by programming we tell it
what to do in our language and a
compiler or an interpreter converts that
into a language which computer
understands
and the computer finally acts on it so
there are many programming languages
over there
like c c plus plus c sharp python java
etc all of them have their own benefits
and drawback the language which we use
to program the arduino is a mixture of c
and c
plus plus which arduino makers call as
wiring
the best part of this arduino language
is that it is uniform across all
platforms
that means it won't matter if you use
windows mac or linux the output of the
code would be the same
so in the next video we will start to
look at arduino programming in a bit
more detail
so let's start by opening up our arduino
ide
once it opens you would see this window
all right and we see void setup and void
loop is written over here
let's discuss whatever we see on the
screen the first line which we see is
white setup right it says void
then setup then a pair of brackets
then a curly bracket then we have two
forward slashes then it says put your
setup code here to run once
and then we have another curly bracket
so what we have done here is
we have declared a mandatory function
known as setup
and this is how you declare functions in
arduino then we have a curly bracket in
most programming languages
these curly brackets indicate a block of
code this left curly bracket means the
start of the block
and this right bracket shows the end of
the block
whatever code which goes inside this
block belongs to this function
the arduino id would help you recognize
the blocks of codes
when you click on these brackets for
example when you click here
it would highlight this bracket
automatically that means
this is the start of your function and
this is the end of your function
whenever you click here then it would
highlight the ending can you see that
all right then we see these two forward
slashes
these forward slashes mean a single line
command whenever we write a comment
compiler entirely ignores whatever is
written after that
so coming back to void setup this
mandatory function contains
all the lines of code which we want
arduino to run once when it is turned on
or when we press reset button
we'll talk more on this in coming
lectures similarly there is void loop
in this section we write all the code
which we want arduino to run
all the time repeatedly that means
whatever is written in this section
would run until the arduino is switched
off the void loop
runs after void setup so in the next
lecture we would see the blink led
example
which we used to test our arduino in a
little more detail we will understand
each part of that code
so see you in the next lecture so till
now we have understood that the two
functions void setup and void loop
are the bare minimum requirement to run
our code successfully
why are they mandatory i will just show
you in a moment i am removing these
functions
and i'm hitting compile the compiler has
passed us with errors
just read them undefined reference to
set up undefined reference to loop
that means it is expecting that we must
define these functions now i will
bring back these functions now i'll hit
compile once again
now the compiler has successfully
compiled the code so with that we can
say arduino ids compiler
expects these two functions like some
other programming languages expect the
main function
without that we won't be able to run the
code we would get an error as you saw so
now we will see some more concepts in
the blink led experiment
so for that we'll go to files
examples basics and then blink
all right so this is our blink example
this is that same code which you used
to test your arduino so we see a huge
chunk of lines here
this is a block of multi-line comments
like we saw a single line comment in the
previous video we start a multi-line
comment by a forward slash followed by a
star
and then we write whatever we want and
then we end it
by a star followed by a forward slash so
anything which is written in between is
ignored by the compiler you may ask then
why do we write comment the answer is
the comments help us to document the
code and they also help the other
readers of the code to understand what
is done by the author of the code
comments also help the author himself
to recall what he did when he sees his
code at the latest date
since comments are totally ignored by
the compiler not writing them won't make
any difference
for example if i remove this comment
and compile the code it will still
compile and with the comments also it
will run just like that
since these comments don't serve any
technical purpose in the code
most developers develop a habit of not
writing that comment which is certainly
not a good practice it is always advised
to write comments for the reasons which
i have already told so now
i will tell you about the white spaces
and case sensitivity the spaces which
you see here
here here etc like here
here won't make any difference as the
compiler would ignore them like the
comments now what i mean to say by this
is that we can add as many spaces
as we want wherever we want
and the compiler won't say anything to
us
it will still successfully compile the
code
like this all right but what we can't do
is we can't add spaces in between
like this otherwise you will get an
error if you compile now
just see that how many errors we have
got so now you will ask what's the
purpose of white spaces white spaces
basically help us
indent the code it makes it easier for
us to identify the blocks of code
it also makes the code look beautiful
for example
if i write something like this
what do you think this code looks better
or this code looks better obviously this
one
all right so proper indentation is
important
now coming to case sensitivity arduino
language is case sensitive what i mean
by that is
the small character would come as small
and the capital character would come as
capital
you can't interchange that for example
this void cannot be written as
this it will give an error
white does not name a type right in this
pin mode you see we cannot write
pin mode as the spin mode
right then also it will give an error
so same goes for everything what you see
here like this high
cannot be written as high
or anything for that matter you have to
write it exactly like
this don't worry if you find it too
difficult to remember you will get a
hang of it very soon remember what i
told about programming
it is the game of practice it is very
common to mess up so the arduino ide has
built-in provision to help us with that
what i mean to say by that is if you
ever mess up the casing by mistake
you would see that this is no more
coming in orange color
right now it is coming back in orange
color
same goes here so if you ever see that
these critical words are not showing up
in color form you can guess that you
have made a mistake now let's see what
is done here in void setup
it says pin mode led built-in
output this pin mode is a built-in
function which configures the specified
pin to behave either as an input or an
output
this input and output is in reference to
the arduino if something is going into
the arduino through that pin
we would configure it as input or if
something is coming out of arduino
through that pin
it will be output in our case the
built-in led would need some sort of
output from arduino
so we will use output so if we see this
line
in a little more detail we have written
pin mode then there is an open bracket
then we have written led built in then
there is a comma then there is output
then there is bracket close and there is
a semicolon
i won't be surprised if you have not
noticed this semicolon till now
i won't be surprised because it is very
very common to forget this semicolon
this semicolon
marks the end of a statement that means
we are telling the compiler we are done
with the statement
we have finished one line if we remove
the semicolon
we would get an error you see expected
semicolon before this
so back to that what this line means is
we have called
a built-in function called pin mode
which has two arguments
the first argument is the pin number
which we want to configure
and the second argument tells the
configuration which we wanted to act as
this built-in led is connected to pin
number 13 of arduino so we are telling
arduino to set the configuration of pin
number 13
as output okay this is what this line is
doing
also note that this line is written
inside the block of void setup
can you see that right one more thing
which i would like you to note is
this led built in the compiler is
automatically replacing this led built
in
with pin number 13. also note that the
compiler is not changing the led
built-in to 13
magically it has been fed somewhere else
in the arduino libraries
we will talk about libraries in coming
lectures but what i want to say right
now is
this is equivalent to this for those
people who felt a little uncomfortable
when i said
we are calling a function here which has
two arguments
i just want all of those people to know
that we will talk about functions
calling functions arguments of the
functions in a lecture
in which we talk about creating custom
functions then you will be able to
relate what i said here exactly
but for now just understand we use pin
mode function
like this we will have to use it
whenever we have to configure a pin
and using this inside setup means that
we want this function to run
once whenever we turn on the arduino or
reset our arduino
all right so now we will see what we
have done in void loop
the first thing which we see is digital
right when it is led built in
then we have high okay so the digital
right
is an inbuilt function which is used to
manipulate the digital pins
and we can also manipulate analog pins
using digital write if the pin is
declared as output
in setup using pin mode digital write
will write a value of 5 volt if we use
high and to 0 if we use low but do make
sure that you have declared the pin as
output
otherwise you may see unexpected results
then after this line we have
delay the value of 1000 in that as the
name suggests
the function would pause the code here
for a specified amount of time
in our case it is 1000 milliseconds
which is one second
whenever we use delay the entire state
of arduino is preserved and nothing
happens during that time
then we have another digital write which
would write low
to the led built in that means the led
will turn off here the led will turn on
here it will turn off and this another
delay will keep it off
for one second and this entire process
would keep on repeating unless we turn
off the arduino as this is inside
white loop so if we change the value of
this delay to 500
we would see the change in blinking
pattern i would like you to try changing
the value to your desired value
and comment down below if you were able
to see the change now i would like to
tell you
that you can also store this delay value
into an imaginary container known as a
variable we can do that by
writing int my delay
value is equal to 100.
you can also choose some other name over
here there are some rules to deciding
the variable name and you would
gradually get to know those rules
as we progress along the course so now
we can take this value
and replace it here
so now while the arduino is looping on
this code it will take
my delay as 100 instead of some other
value what benefit do we have to use
this
we can change our value to any other
value
like this or this
if we need to change the value instead
of changing here
twice and making our code error prone
we can just change the value here
it will save our time and also make our
code less prone to errors
we can also make our own variable to
define led pin
and we would do that by hint
led pin is equal to 13
and now we will take this led pin and we
will replace it here
right so this code will work exactly
like the earlier code and it would work
flawlessly
the benefit of using our own pin is that
we can change the pin which we want to
use
later for example now i have decided to
use pin number
two instead of pin number 30. so instead
of changing the pin number
from 13 to 2 everywhere i can just
change it to 2 here
so now automatically the compiler will
pick the value of 2
of led pin and replace them here now
some of you must have noticed the way
how i am writing led pin
like small ln and capital p what's the
reason behind that
now since we cannot keep spaces between
our variable names
and led and pin are two different names
so the compiler will throw an error
and some people came up with the
solution that to name variables like
this
we can keep the first character of the
second word capital in order to
differentiate
so now our eyes are able to
differentiate between led and pin
properly
and this technique is known as camel
casing if i have to use more than two
words
what i can do is like this
so now my eyes are able to read my led
pin as three different words
instead of one word but for the compiler
it is just the one word
and now some of you must be wondering
what is int why we have declared it here
right so in the next video we'll talk
about this int
and the other data types variables and
more about
variable scope see you in the next video
so now we will discuss about variables
what exactly are variables
variables are nothing but they are kind
of a virtual containers
which is used by a compiler and we store
some values in those containers
there are different kinds of data which
we can hold in different kinds of
container
for example at your home you store sugar
in some kind of specific container you
store
tea in the tea container oil in the oil
container similarly in programming as
well
we have some sort of containers and
those can store some sort of specific
data
the variables are available in different
sizes and we will be talking about just
the default variables which are used in
the arduino programming
the thing to note here is the bigger the
container the bigger the value it can
store
the first kind of data type which we
will see is int if you can recall
we used in in the previous video when we
declared our led pins and our own
delay values right so int is basically a
container which can hold
integer values and i hope you're aware
what integers are
if not i will just quickly tell you that
the number line is there the whole
numbers from
negative infinity to positive infinity
are all
integers which you can see here in this
video like minus 4 minus 3 minus 2
0 1 2 3 4. the numbers greater than 0
are positive integers and
the numbers less than 0 are negative
integers the default integer which we
use in arduino programming
has a range of minus 32 768
to positive 32 767 right what this means
is the size of integer
can hold these many values if you try to
store value
beyond this range the values will
overflow now i will tell you
how to declare an integer in programming
language
first of all we write int then we name
the variable
like in this case the name of the
variable is value and then we assign a
value to it for example
we have assigned a value of 5 here right
and then a semicolon
we can also assign it like this we write
int then value
and we do not initialize it with any
value if we do not initialize any value
the default value is zero i'm going to
say is if you do not initialize the
variable the default value which it
holds is
0. we will see more about integers in a
moment so before i can demonstrate how
int exactly works in the code i need you
to understand
these three critical functions first one
of them is serial.begin
bracket 9600 bracket close basically
this function enables the serial
communication between arduino
and the computer what serial
communication is
and what these functions are we will
talk in detail
in coming lectures but for now just
understand we
have to write this statement whenever we
want any communication to happen between
the arduino
and the computer then there is
serial.print bracket
semicolon right we use this function
whenever we want to print something on
the serial monitor
we will see serial monitor in a moment
and then we have serial.println
the difference between serial.print and
serial.println is that serial.println
just
adds an additional line after printing
whatever is
ours to print now without any further
delay we'll just see
how integer works so now let's start
afresh
by learning about integers let me open a
new file
all right so i'm declaring my first ever
integer above void setup
like this end my
variable is equal to 5
it is similar to something which we saw
in the presentation when i told you
about integers
now to see the value of my variable i
will start
serial communication with my computer
like this
and now to see the value i will print
the value serial dot println
my variable so now i'll upload the code
it's done uploading and now i will see
the serial monitor
so you see it has printed the value of 5
that means the value of my variable is 5
as we have declared
similarly when i said if we don't
initialize it
the value is 0. we'll upload the code
and see it again
let me name the file first
right if now we have not declared it so
now we will see the value
it says zero so now i will be telling
you about how we can
modify our variables for example
the first thing which we can do is we
will take our variable
and add 2 to it
so first operator which you see is plus
these are arithmetic operators and we
will be discussing more about these
shortly now if you print our variable
serial dot println
my variable
right so the answer would be 2.
so the value of my variable initially
was 0 and now we have added 2 to it
so we have 2 here now for example if we
had initiated it
with 5 so now we will get
7 right okay
as expected now the variable value is 7
right so now we will manipulate it
by subtracting 2 from it
now again we will get 5. let me tell you
that shortcut to open the serial monitor
is
this button and then we will print it
right 5 7 and 5 i hope i am making some
sense
similarly there is a multiplication
operator and a division operator
what we can do is let's say
my variable is equal to my variable
into 5 let's say now we will print my
variable
so what will we get in guesses
we'll get 25 right so 5 was the value of
my variable and we multiplied it by 5 so
we have 25 so now let's divide
my variable by 25 divide by
25 what will we get one right
right we got one now the important thing
which i want you to notice
the integer variable can only hold
integers it cannot hold
fractions for example i'll tell you let
me delete all this code
for example if my variable was 3 right
and what if we divide my variable
by 2 mathematically
the answer should be 1.5 but since
our integer variable can't hold decimal
values so can you guess what will it
print now
it will print one why
because it can only hold integer part of
any decimal the answer was
1.5 but it will pick only the integer
value
so if you want decimal values as well we
will use float and we will soon learn
about float
now there is another interesting
operator known as modulo
it will give us the remainder after
division
let's say my variable is 6 okay
and i want to get the value of the
remainder we will say
my variable
equal to my variable modulo
the symbol of modulo is percentage sign
if we divide 6 by
2 so it will completely divide by 2
right so the remainder will be
0. so if we print my variable we should
get a value of 0
right as expected
if we divide six by three
then also we'll get a remainder of zero
but if we divide six by four we get a
remainder of
two right we will get two here now
as expected now can you guess what if we
divided by
five what remainder will be
we'll get one right as expected
so these were the main arithmetic
operators which we can use
to modify our variables now for example
we have more than one variables in our
code
my second variable
and the value of that is 5. now what we
can do is
now let's see what will we get my
variable plus
my second variable right
so can you guess what will we get we'll
get 11.
right as expected and what if we
subtract it
are we correct absolutely similarly we
can also multiply
what should we get 6 multiplied by 5 is
30 right what another thing which we can
do is we can store
these values here our results are not
getting stored
here they are just being displayed what
if we want to store it
we can take another variable my third
variable
and let's not initialize it okay so what
we can do is
let's take my third variable
okay and let's store the value
of my variable
plus my second value
and let's print the third variable
we should get 11 here exactly
so similarly we can do whatever we want
with the variables
but the most important thing which i
want you to notice is before
using the variable we have to declare it
for example
if we do not declare my third variable
okay and try to do something with it
the compiler will throw us an error my
third variable was not declared in this
scope
all right we'll discuss about scope in
coming videos
just wait for some time you also need to
note that
you have to declare the variable before
using it right
you cannot do this as well for example
you
try to declare your third variable here
right then also you will get an error
you have to declare it before using it
you cannot declare it after using it
right
the last important operator which you
need to know to be comfortable with the
course
is the increment and the decrement
operator there are two types of each
one is post increment and pre-increment
and post decrement and pre-decrement
all right the purpose of increment
operator is to increase the value of
variable by one
and the purpose of decrement operator is
to decrease the value of our variable by
1. i'll show you this by an example we
have
my variable and the value of my variable
is 6. so now
if i take my variable and do
plus plus this plus plus is post
increment operator okay and now if i
print my variable
you will see that we will get 7
right so now if i use
pre-increment operator then also
we'll get the value of 7 see
so now you may ask what is the
difference between post increment and
pre-increment
well there is actually a difference and
you will get to know that difference
when we use
this operator in some expression for
example
let's see it here
if i increment the value of my variable
like this like you see in serial println
then we will get value of 6
right as you can see and the reason
behind this is
in a post increment operator the value
is first used in the expression
and then it is incremented
now if i
use a pre increment operator then we
will see we get
7. so by this we can understand
by pre-increment operator the value is
first incremented and then used in the
expression
similarly there is a decrement operator
if i do
my variable minus minus
will get 5 because my variable was
originally 6
so we decremented it by 1 so hence we
get 5.
i hope this concept was clear to you
this concept will be used multiple times
during our course so if you have any
questions you can comment down below
and in the next video we will look at
the float data type
so now we will look at the float data
type this data type is capable of
holding
decimal places as well like we saw in
the integer it cannot hold decimals
the float can hold decimals as well and
the default float which we use
in arduino programming is precise up to
7 decimal places
let me explain you in a better way like
for example
the number you see here is a real number
it is 863.267
right so in integer if we try to store
this
that would store only 863. it will just
ignore
0.267 so if you want to use
0.267 as well in our memory so we will
use
a float data type so how do we declare
that
we write float then space then the name
of that float
variable in our case it is value equals
to
5.6 or some other value which you want
then a semicolon
you can also start a float uninitialized
like we have done here so let's now see
the demonstration of how float is used
in a programming we will declare the
variable
my float variable is equal to
7.8 for example
let's see right we can see the value
of 7.8 now let's see what happens if we
try to
store 7.8
in an int variable
as i told you in the presentation we'll
get seven
right can you see the difference now now
we will just quickly see
the limitation which we had while using
int variable
that while dividing we could not store
the decimal part
so we will see if we can store that in
float variable or not
let's see it quickly i'll take my float
variable
and i'll divide it by
2 okay and we'll see the my float
variable then
let's comment this statement
all right 7.8 divided by 2 is
3.9 we can use all the operators which
we used in the int variable like plus
minus divide multiply
increment decrement and floats as well
okay
so you can try that on your own and
comment down below if you face any
problem
so now we will take a look at the bool
or boolean data type
they can be used interchangeably right
but we prefer
to use bool so the pool data type
holds one of the two values true or
false
that means if something is true or if
something is
false for example we can declare a
boolean variable
by writing pool then the name of the
in our case it is is tall equals to
true or false we'll take another example
bool is fit is equal to false semicolon
so this way we can declare a boolean
variable but i want you to note is
that one high or true are considered
same
by the id also 0 low
and false are also considered same by id
by id i mean
the arduino ide right and anything other
than 0
is also considered true by the id we'll
look at
what exactly this means in the coding
now let's understand
the boolean variable in the coding we
will initialize it by
writing bool we will then name it and
initialize the value of
say one as i told you
one high
or true all these three hold
the same meaning and similarly zero
low and false
all hold the same meaning if we try to
print the variable
let's see what happens it will print
zero right because false is zero if we
use
low then also it will print zero same
goes for true
if i use true here it will print one
and the other thing which i told you if
you use anything other than
0 that would evaluate to 1 let's see
that also for example i used 78
let's see what happens it still gave 1
okay so that means bool can either store
0 or 1
that's all and what's the purpose of
boolean operator
we check if something is true in the
code we'll see
examples while doing our experiments
shortly i would like to tell you
if we want to check some condition is
true or false or we can initialize our
condition as well if something is true
then only we have to do certain tasks
you will understand more about
boolean data type when we progress in
the course like when we study about
conditionals or when we study logical
operators or when we study
the comparison operators we will now
move on to another data type which is
known as
byte the next data type which we have is
byte
so as the name suggests it is a byte
long data type
it can store up to eight bits of data so
as we all know eight bits equals to one
byte okay
so a byte is just like an integer but
the only difference is
the range is 0 to 255. so if you're sure
that your
variable is not going to exceed 255 you
can always use a byte type
data type so using a byte data type will
save your
arduino memory so we will now see how to
declare a byte
we will write byte space name of the
variable
equals to and the value which we want to
add in that then a semicolon
we can also declare it without
initializing the variable and in that
case
the default value it will store is 0
just like integer
so let's just quickly declare our byte
and let's print it
right so now we will look at our next
data type
which is char which is a short for
character
as the name suggests it can hold a
single character
any character present on the keyboard
for that matter including all the
symbols like comma
question mark numbers like 1 2 3
characters like abc
small caps everything let's see how we
declare a character
we write char space name of the variable
equals to and the character which we
want to use
and that is enclosed in single inverted
commas and then
a semicolon we can also declare our
character like this
as we have seen it many times already
the thing to note about characters is
that it is still stored as a number what
i mean by that
is there is a full ascii table each
character
on the keyboard corresponds to a number
for example you can see
a capital a is 65 and a small a is
97 right similarly you can see the
entire table it contains
all the characters which are present on
the keyboard and each character
has its own number so we'll look at this
in a bit more detail
using our coding all right so we will
declare a character
care my care
is equal to right
now we will print it right
we get an a now if i write 65
which is the ascii value of capital a
you can refer ascii table to verify then
also it will print a
and let's have a look right it printed a
now still these are numbers that means
it should be possible
for us to perform some arithmetic on
that for example
if i take a here and add 1 here
right so what should we get we should
get 66
as expected why because the value of a
was 65 and it added 1 to that
so we get 66 right a char data type
occupies one byte in the memory
okay so i hope you understood the char
data type i can understand if you got
a bit confused with the character
arithmetic don't worry about that right
now
this information is enough to start our
projects
so now we have discussed all the
important data types like end
float char bool byte and you have also
learned
when to use which type of data type so
i'm pretty sure that you won't face any
issues
while performing your experiments
although there are more data types like
arrays and strings which are slightly
more complicated than data types which
we have already discussed
and they would also involve the usage of
loops so we will cover them after
discussing loops
as that would make it easier for you to
understand for now we will move on to
our next topic
which is variable scope and qualifiers
see you in the next video
now since we are familiar with the data
types and what variables are
we can easily understand what is
variable scope and qualifiers
so let's start by understanding what is
scope in many programming languages
including arduino's programming language
it matters where you have declared your
variable
speaking of which we have two kinds of
variables global variables and
local variables a global variable is the
one which can be seen by
every function in the program while
local variables are only visible to the
function
in which they are declared in the
arduino environment any variable
declared outside of a function example
void setup or void loop or any other
custom function
is a global variable so let's start by
understanding that in a proper manner
so what positions would qualify for
writing a global variable
the first position which we see is just
above white setup
the place where my cursor is blinking
right now for example i write
int myvariable
is equal to 6. so in this case my
variable
is a global variable
as i told the global variable is
accessible in all the functions
let's see that by printing my variable
in void setup
right it will print here as well it will
print
in void loop as well let's make an
identifier
so that we can identify in which
function it got printed
serial.println printing in
setup all right and let's differentiate
printing in blue all right
let's have a delay here because it will
print very fast otherwise
okay let's see that now
right printing in setup and printing in
loop
it is printing again and again because
we have written that in loop
as we already know loop function will
run until and unless we turn off the
arduino so that means
my variable could be accessed by white
setup as well as
while loop that means this is a global
variable
now we will see a local variable instead
of declaring it above
void setup let's declare it in void
setup
so now let's try to compile this we
should get an error
why because my variable was not declared
in the scope it is saying
in void loop you did not declare my
variable so i don't know what my
variable is so let's comment out this
line
now it will compile okay it compiles
successfully and it will just print
in setup once right
if we declare my variable
in void loop and just uncomment this
line
now we'll get an error in white setup
because it was declared in void loop but
it was not declared in void setup
you see in void setup my variable was
not declared in the scope
now let's see a consolidated example of
using global and local variables
together
the variable which i declare here is in
my global
variable is equal to 789 so let's
print it here and let's also
print it here okay this one is
accessible to
both white setup and while loop let's
declare a local variable here
and my local variable
is equal to 852. so this is a local
variable and it will be accessible only
to white setup
now let's try to print this
my local variable note that we can use
same names
if we are using a different scope for a
variable for example we can use
my local variable in void loop as well
and we can give it a different value
1 2 3 for example and let's
print this as well so what should be the
expected result when we print my global
variable
it should print 789 and when we print my
local variable when the code is running
in void setup
it should print 852 and when it is
running in while loop it should print
one two three
so let's upload this code
is that as expected let's see printing
in setup it printed my global variable
which is 789 and my local variable which
is
852 right now in printing in loop
it printed my global variable 789 and my
local variable which was
123. so i hope you are clear with the
scope of the variable
when programs start to get larger and
more complex local variables are useful
way to ensure
that only one function has access to its
own variables
this prevents programming errors when
one function modifies the variables used
by other functions
this concept will get clearer to you as
we progress in the course
so now we will look at qualifiers
qualifiers basically define
additional behavior to our variables
there are two main kinds of qualifiers
one is constant and one is static the
constant qualifier is declared by using
const keyword it is a variable qualifier
that modifies the behavior of the
variable
making a variable read-only this means
the variable can be used just as any
other variable of its type
but its value cannot be changed you will
get a compiler error if you try to alter
a value to a constant variable
we will just see by an example we will
declare our variable
constant int my variable
is equal to 5. now my variable is a
constant integer you cannot add anything
to it you cannot subtract anything to it
you just can't alter it
now let's try to alter it let's see what
happens
we got an error assignment of a read
only variable my variable
however you can use constant variables
for doing the math
for example i take another variable here
is equal to my variable into
5 right
since this is not possible we'll remove
it we'll try to
print the value of my second variable
right so can you guess what will we get
we got 25 right because my variable was
5 and we multiplied it by 5 so we got
25.
so you may wonder what purpose do
constant variables
serve in the code well we can use
constant variables wherever we don't
want our variables to change their value
for example there are constants like pi
which is 3.14
and we can have our arduino pins as
constants like if we don't want to
change them in the code
i would also like to tell you that there
is an alternative in c
plus plus language to define our
constant variables
which is hash defined as define is a
useful c plus plus component that allows
the programmer to give a name to a
constant value
before the program is compiled define
constants in arduino don't take up any
program memory space on the chip
the compiler will replace the references
to these constants with the defined
value at the compile time
so let's see this by an example we start
by writing hash
define then the name of the variable
which you want
let's say pi okay and the value of that
variable which you want it can be
anything for that matter it can be an
integer it can be a float it can be a
character
so let's say the value of pi is 3.14
right also note that we don't terminate
the defined lines
by a semicolon we just write this so
whenever we use
pi in our code the compiler will replace
the value which is written next to it
there the compiler won't care if it
makes any sense or not you have to make
sure that it makes sense
okay so now let's declare another
variable
of float type and let's name it area
of circle okay
and let's do the math pi into
r square let's say r is 5 so
right and now let's print the area of
circle
right let's upload it we see
it has automatically picked up the value
of pi from here and
it has done the math and it is giving
the answer to us right
as hash defined doesn't use any memory
in the arduino it is really tempting to
use hash define
but it certainly has some downsides the
compiler will replace
all the references to pi in the code and
you will start facing problems
so it is recommended that you avoid
using hash define so use constant int
in place of hash define unless you are
falling short of memory
so in the next video we'll talk about
the static qualifier
see you in the next video so we will
discuss about static qualifier in this
video
let me just quickly clean up this mess
first because it's looking so
confusing so just observe what's
happening let's declare a variable here
int xyz is equals to
zero let's increment it here and let's
print it let's see what happens
can you see that we initialized it by
zero we incremented by one and then we
printed the value so when the loop
started again
the value would be incremented to two
let me stop this auto scroll
the value will increment to two then
three then four and five
and six and then so on okay it will keep
running
until i stop it
so in this case we have declared xyz as
a global variable but i would like to
tell you that it is not a good practice
to declare many global variables
so we should try that we use local
variables as much as possible
so let's try to use it as a local
variable we will remove it from here
and we will declare it here right we
declared index y
equal to zero then x y z plus one
then we will increment it by one and
then we will print it okay
let's see what difference will it create
can you explain why is this happening
okay we initialize it by zero we
incremented it
we printed it okay and then
it was again initialized to zero then
again it was
incremented by one and then printed so
it will keep on printing one
unless i stop this loop so now we are in
a trouble
if we declare it in loop then it would
reset every time the loop is called
and it is recommended that we don't use
global variables that much so what is
the solution
the solution is that we use a static
qualifier
to do that we will just add static in
front of
our variable what this will do is this
will just initialize it by zero
and it will not reset it to zero every
time the loop is called
let's see if it solves our problem
yup it did solve our problem so using a
static data qualifier is a good way to
preserve
the data of our variables between the
function call i hope it was clear to you
please comment down if you have any
questions see you in the next video
in this video we will look at the
comparison operators
comparison operators are basically some
operators which would tell you if
something which you're trying to compare
is true or not they would return a
boolean value of either true
or false so we have about five or six
comparison operators we will just look
at them
in a moment the first operator which we
have is a lesson operator and is
represented by
a less than symbol then we have a
greater than operator
then we have less than equal to then we
have
greater than equal to then we have equal
to equal to and then
we have not equal right so we have a
total of
six comparison operators we will just
look at them what they exactly mean
let me comment this out first uh let's
have our variables
end variable one right
let's say it is seven and we have int
variable two and it is eight
let's try to compare them variable one
less than variable two as i told you
this operator returns something
which is true or false so what will
happen here is since variable one
is less than variable 2 right so it will
print
1. let's see
so now let's do one thing let us make
this variable 1
as 9. now we should get 0 because this
statement will become false
right as we expected so now can you
guess if i make variable 1 as 8
what will happen let's see
this should return 0 yes why because 8
is not less than 8 okay it is equal to 8
but it is not less than 8.
so we'll talk about this condition very
soon okay now we will have
the greater than operator let's replace
this right and change the variable
to 9 back okay so what do you think it
should return it should return true
because
variable 1 is greater than variable 2 of
course i hope you understood these two
operators
then we have less than equal to we use
it like
this a less than symbol and equal to
symbol this is a less than equal to
operator what this does is it will
return true
if the value on the left side is lesser
than
the value on the right side or it is
equal to the value on
right side you got my point so
previously when i made
variable 1 equal to eight and variable
two also eight it returned
zero but in this case it will return one
because eight is equal to
eight so let's try that
right so similarly a greater than equal
to sign
also works like this you can experiment
this on your own
then we'll look at the equal to equal to
sign equal to equal to sign means
it will compare if some values are equal
or not
it will return true only and only if a
value is exactly equal
in our case we will get one because our
value are eight and eight
we got one if i make it nine for example
we should get zero
then we have a not equal to operator we
use it like
we take an exclamation mark and then i
equal to symbol
this operator will tell you false only
if the two values are equal
okay in all the other cases you will get
a 1 not equals 2 right if some value is
equal to some other value it will say it
is
false because that is equal but if you
take any value
in our case for example variable 1 is 9
and variable 2 is 8 we should get
a 1 because that is true
right so we have covered all the
operators and how they work so you may
be wondering now what is the use of
these operators
in programming well these operators will
help you compare the values for example
you make a project in which you have to
compare the values of the sensors so you
may have to use these operators
right and when you use these operators
you will get some
decision making capability in your code
i would like you to note
one important thing about the equal to
operator many people make a mistake
while using the equal to operator
they use 1 equal to sign instead of 2
equal to signs while 1 equal to sign
is the assignment operator that means
you are assigning a value to a variable
like in this case we have assigned a
value of 9 to variable 1
we have used one equal to sign okay and
when we use
double equals to that means we are
trying to compare something
so to avoid making mistakes i really
recommend that you double check
the operator which you have used i will
talk about this once more
in the control structures when we study
about the if conditional block
and in the next video we will learn
about the logical operators
in this video we will look at logical
operators the concept of logical
operators is very simple we use logical
operators
whenever we want to take decisions in
the code each operand
is applied to some condition which may
be either true or false
we'll just see that in a moment so
basically there are three logical
operators
and operator or operator and a not
operator
so let's see how it works in coding so
the and operator
the and operator is represented by two
ampersand signs
these signs can you see that then we
have or operator and which is
represented by
two straight lines we'll find this
symbol just above your
enter key and then we have a not
operator
it is an exclamation mark that's all
so let's see the and operator so the and
operator expects that all the conditions
which
we are using in it are true in order to
return a true
these operators also return a boolean
value of either true or false
they also operate on boolean values
which is either true or false like i
told you
they work on some conditions please hold
on as i further clarify this
let's start with the and operator let me
just open the cl monitor so that we can
understand it side by side
the first thing which we have written is
the lessons about and operator
it is printed exactly as we have written
it
okay then it is true and true is true
and true is written like this
okay then we have written true which is
the boolean value
then the operator and operator and then
another
boolean value which is again true the
true and true
returns a true and both of the two
conditions are true
then the answer is true for all the
other conditions it is
false for example true and false is
false
false and true is false false and false
is also false
so whenever we use it to take decisions
we tell the compiler
you have to proceed only if both the
conditions are true
okay if they're false you don't have to
proceed okay i hope it is clear
if it is not clear don't worry we will
just understand while we write our main
programs
then we have printed some empty lines so
that we can have a space over here then
we will see
the or operator this is the or operator
it is printing the lessons about
our operator with the or operator even
if one condition is true
then the resultant will be true it will
be false only if
all the conditions are false for example
we can see
true and true is true true and false is
also true false and true is also true
false and false is false right then
again we have printed some lines
so that we can see the gap here then we
will see the not operator the not
operator basically just reverses the
value of the boolean for example
the not of true is we have used the
operator here
and the not of true is false as you can
see it's zero then the not of false is
true
right it has just reversed the values it
is very useful when we write our
conditional blocks
which we will see shortly all right so
let me just
make some changes so that you can
connect it with the comparison operators
which we used earlier
okay so instead of straight away writing
true here let's take
5 greater than 3 which is true right and
instead of writing true here
we can say seven is less than eight
okay both the conditions are true hence
we will also get
true right then also we got true
because both the conditions were true if
we make one condition false
let's say here 8 is less than
5 which is false right so true and false
is
false let's see that
right this is giving false we'll just
quickly look at
our condition let's say both the
conditions are false
let's make false conditions 5 is less
than
2 which is false 4 is greater than
9 which is also false so we should get
right which is this line false and false
is
0. i can understand it can be a bit
confusing for some people but i can
assure you that
once you start writing the codes on your
own you won't face any problem
while using these operators and even if
you still have some problem we are
always there to help you
you can always comment down in the
comment sections so see you in the next
video
we will now look at control structures
so basically till now we have seen
that the code is executed line by line
that means the lines of codes are
executed in the order
in which we have written them for
example we have written some code to
perform action one then we have written
some code to perform
action two then in that case the action
one will happen before
action two when the action do completes
then the action three will take place so
similarly there is a controlled flow of
code where we can decide which parts of
the code we want to execute based on
some conditions we start our code
and then there is a condition that
condition can be anything for that
matter
and based on that condition if it is
true or false we can take some other
actions
let's say we have a switch we'll check
if switch is pressed then we want to
take some action
if it is not pressed we want some other
action to take place and the flow of
code will depend on that condition
either it will go this way either it
will go this way and after completing
that task it will
jump back to the main code execute the
lines which are present in the main code
and then
it will exit so the first control
structure which we will study is
the if statement we will understand
about if statement and we will see how
to use if conditions in our code in the
next video
so let us see the if condition whenever
we write an if statement we write a
condition
along with that let's say we are trying
to use a if block
will take a condition which we want
should be true if it is true
then whatever we write in the if block
will execute and then
it will move on to the statement which
is written just after if statement okay
and it will execute that as well
and then it will exit but if in case it
is false
then it will entirely ignore whatever is
written inside the if block and it will
straight away jump to
the code which is written after if
statement it will execute that
and then it will exit let us quickly
look at the syntax of if statement
let's see this is our code we have
written some statements we write
if then we start a bracket we write our
condition
let's say something greater than
something or if something is true
if something is false if something is
not true anything for that matter i will
put a condition in this bracket then we
close the bracket and then we open up
the curly bracket
then we write all the statements which
we want to execute then we close the
bracket and then we move on to
write more statements in our code so
this is the syntax of if statement
so let us try this in our coding so we
have an example here
we'll write cl dot begin 9600 here so
that we can communicate with the
computer so we will write the first
statement serial.println
this line should print irrespective of
anything and yes this line will print
irrespective of anything
then we will write if true serial dot
println
this line should print
only if the condition
is true please note that we don't use a
semicolon here
let's write another statement
if false serial.print
ln this statement will not print
as the condition is false it is over
and then again we'll write one line
which should execute
irrespective of anything let's say this
only this line
should also print irrespective of
anything
so let's upload this code and see what
happens
so we see this line should print
irrespective of anything this line
should print only if the condition is
true this line should also print
irrespective of anything
did you know that when the condition was
false the block did not execute
let me do one more thing let's see a
block of code
executing let's print one more line here
the second line
right so now this line should also print
there
the second line because it was the part
of this if block so whatever is written
inside this block
it will execute no matter what once the
condition is true but of course
writing true and false exactly like this
does not make any sense right so we have
to
build our conditions let's say if 5 is
greater than 3
then this should execute we'll see the
same result because this evaluates to
true
right so basically we should keep in
mind that a boolean
value should come inside this okay in
this bracket there should be a boolean
value
then only it would be able to take some
decision based on that boolean value so
now we can complicate the condition as
well
like for example and 2 greater than 5
but this is false right like we saw in
the and operator
both the conditions should be true in
order to return true
right but this is true and this is false
so we'll now see that this block of code
will also not execute
let's see right as expected
this line should print irrespective of
anything this line will print anyway
this line will also print anyway so now
let's try to print this line
we'll make this condition true 2 is less
than
5 or 5 is less than 2. this condition is
true because
one of the condition is true right 2 is
less than 5 that is true but 5 is not
less than 2
this is false but in the or condition
one statement has to be true to get the
resultant as true
so this line should print now let's see
yep so we were able to print this line
because we made the condition true
okay so when we will be making our
projects what kind of conditions will we
use we will be using conditions like
the sensor value on the left hand side
should be greater than the sensor value
on the right hand side
then these things should happen so i
think you were able to relate with this
thing
okay now i will tell you another thing
for example i took a bool
many people do mistake in this so let's
start by taking a bool
my bowl is equal to false so now what i
want to do is
i want to print these lines only if my
bool
is true so i'm comparing it if it is
true then only
it should print but this is not true
right because the value of my bool was
false so that's why the resultant was
false
so hence the lines present in this if
block will not execute
now if we write false then it will
execute because it is actually false
so we can see these lines got printed so
now i'll talk about the mistake which
people do
what they will do is they will use one
equal to sign instead of
two signs so what will happen is the
compiler will assign
a value of true to my bool and the
resultant
value of my bool will become one okay
and this block of code will execute
right so the expression which we write
in the if condition
is executed first and then the value of
that thing is taken into consideration
if it is true or false
okay in our case my bool was assigned a
value of true
and then the value of my bool was used
please take care you use
double equals to if you want to compare
the values
now we can do nesting of ifs as well
what nesting means like this is our if
block
we can write more if blocks inside are
the parent if block
let's say we write another if if true
serial dot
print this is nested
if right we can write another if inside
that if
false serial.println
this is another line which will not
execute so this was nesting of if this
is the parent if this is a child if and
this is
a further child of this if right we can
see like this
this is the flow this bracket closes
here and this bracket closes here
for example in any case the parent if is
false
then all the child lifts will never
execute please keep that in mind
i hope you understood this point i'm
pretty sure that you will be able to
understand it in a better way when you
perform your experiments
so in the next video we'll look at the
else statement
see you in the next video now we will
try to understand the else statement
first of all let us look at the flow of
the code
we always write an else statement
preceded by an if statement
let's have a look at the flow of code
when we use an else block
there's an entry of code there is an if
condition if that is true
the body inside the if block is executed
the body inside
the else block is entirely ignored then
it moves on to code after if statement
after executing that code it would exit
in case if it is false it will
straightaway go to
else block and it will execute the code
which is present inside the else block
and it will ignore the code which is
present inside
the if block after executing the else
block it will go to the main code the
code which is written after the
if statement it will execute that and it
will exit before looking at the syntax
of else block let us compare it with
just the if block so this was the if
statement
in if statement if the condition was
true it would execute the body inside
the if block then it will go to the main
code
execute that and then it will exit so
when we use just the if condition
without else that means we don't define
what we want to happen if the condition
which we have specified
is false if it is false it will entirely
ignore the if body and it will jump to
the main code
but in else we define what we want to
happen if something is false so that we
write in the else block so now let us
look at the syntax of else block we
start by writing if
we specify the condition we open the
bracket we write our actions here if the
condition one is true
then we close the bracket and then we
write else
if if we have more than one conditions
for example if you want different sound
levels of an alarm
based on the temperature ranges for
example at a lower temperature an alarm
would ring slowly
and at another condition let's say
another range it will ring a bit louder
and if it exceeds something then we want
it to
ring at the maximum intensity okay so
these things can be controlled
by if and else blocks okay after writing
else if we write condition two if that
condition is true think
b will happen okay and then finally we
write an else
if none of the conditions is true then
the else block will execute
the thing which you need to notice here
is if the condition one is true it will
execute
the thing a and it will straight away
jump to the main code after this
the control won't go in else if it will
go in else if only if the condition one
was false for example the code was
running here
it found that condition one was false so
it will jump and check if condition 2 is
true or false
if it is true then it will do the thing
b if it is also false
then it will go to else block and do the
thing c we will just understand this
with the coding example so here we have
example
for understanding the else statement
let's do this we'll write if true
serial dot print ln my first statement
so you can see the compiler has
automatically considered this bracket
which was originally for void setup
for the if block okay we have to make
sure we are using our brackets correctly
now after closing the if block we will
write
else serial dot println my
else statement all right so now we will
close
the white setup bracket now let us
upload this code okay
so my first statement got printed
because my initial if condition was true
and it will ignore the else block now
let's make it false
now we will see that statement written
in the else block will print let's have
a look
my statement okay we can do the nesting
in if else statements as well
like we saw in the if video like i can
start another if here
if some other condition will write
another task here so we can use
endless if and else and the nesting of
them as well by now you must be feeling
a little bored by just printing the
statements here and there and not doing
any real things so in the next video i
will show you
a small simulation by using if and else
blocks
so see you in the next video so before i
show you that fl
simulation i would like to show you this
comic
just have a look at this comic for like
5-10 seconds
and if you get the joke in this comic i
can say that you have pretty much
understood
the concepts which we have discussed so
far
okay don't worry if you could not
understand this once you finish the part
where i'm teaching
about functions i'm sure you will be
able to understand it really well
so just in case if you could not
understand this i would say that please
complete that section
and then come back to this comic again
and
i'm pretty sure that you will have a
good laugh
okay so now let's move on to that
simulation i was talking about
so as i told you that i will show you a
simulation of fns blocks in the previous
video so i will just show you
that simulation on the left hand side of
the screen you can see a circuit diagram
and on the right hand side of the screen
you can see the code which i have used
to make this simulation the simulation
tool which you see on the left is
autodesk tinkercad
you can do a google search about it if
you want to know more about this i'll
help you in the comment section if you
face any problem with this
every one of you must have performed the
blink example and i have very clearly
explained you the functions which we
used in that like pin mode digital write
and delay so i will assume that you will
not face any problem
understanding this code so let's begin i
have declared temperature as the global
variable and initialize it with 0. in
the void setup i have written
pin number 678 as output as i want to
connect our led to those pins
so in the loop section i've started with
if i'm trying to tell the compiler
if the value of the temperature is less
than 50 and is also greater than 10
that means it lies between 10 to 50. so
i want to
perform this action please note the
values of 50 and 10 are not
inclusive as we have not used the equal
to sign if you want to include those
values you will have to use an equal to
sign
as well you must be remembering less
than equal to operator and greater than
equal to operator right
you can always revisit the videos if you
have any confusion so coming back to
this i've simply written the code to
blink the led which is connected to pin
number six pin number six is this one
that means this led is connected to pin
number six also note that all the leds
which are connected here
are connected to a common ground which
we have connected like this then we have
written
else if that means if the previous if
was not true then check this condition
if temperature is greater than 50
and temperature is less than 70. that
means the temperature range is
51 to 69. so if this condition is true
then we want to blink the led connected
to pin number seven
which is this one pin number seven this
and then finally we have written else if
none of the conditions is true
then do this thing which is blink the
led which is connected to pin number
eight which is this led so let's say
we have temperature is equal to zero
currently we have hard coded this
temperature
but in your projects you may have some
sensors like lm-35
or dht 11 which will return you the real
time temperature of your room and
code will act accordingly but just to
test these conditions will be taking
some arbitrary values
so let's see in which condition will
this zero fall okay
if temperature is less than 50 or
greater than 10 but it is not relying in
this condition
then it is greater than 50 and less than
so this is also false so ultimately the
else code should run so let me start the
simulation right you can see
else statement was being executed that
means this led is blinking so now
let's change the value from 0 to 52. so
can you guess what will happen
for the value of 52 okay let's see the
value of 52
is less than 50 which is false so
ultimately this condition will be
discarded
it will check this one then so the
temperature is greater than 50 yes
temperature is less than 70 yes so this
condition is true
so hence the led connected to pin number
7 should start blinking
so let's start the simulation so led
connected to pin number 7
has started blinking pin number seven
okay so let's change the temperature
value to 25 so now this condition will
get true so let's start the simulation
right so this led is blinking so one
small homework for you guys is you have
to comment down below what will happen
if i select the value of 100 we can take
a pause of 5 seconds
and just go and comment down below after
then come back and see the results
so led which is connected to pin number
8 is blinking
why so because 100 will not fall in any
of the conditions so the compiler will
execute
the else statement one interesting thing
which i want you to notice is
that right now we have chosen arbitrary
values but with the sensors you will get
really changing values you may get the
values which are changing so
the arduino will act in the real time
okay if you don't change the value and
the sensor changes that value
and we get different values from that
sensor then the arduino will
automatically check
which condition is true right now and it
will execute that statement
and it happens really fast so with the
real sensor you may see led which is
currently blinking may change very
quickly
for example if you light up a candle
near the sensor then the led which is
blinking may change
and then if you remove the candle then
you may see that the other led may start
blinking depending on the condition
which is currently running
so i hope you are clear with this if you
still have any questions you can always
comment down below or send a message to
us
so we will now take a look at loop
structure which is another kind of a
control structure
in this kind of control structure we
will basically learn how to write
instructions in order to repeat
certain tasks instead of writing code
again and again for doing a certain task
we can
learn how to repeat that task again and
again for example
the void loop function which we use in
arduino is a loop structure
whatever we write in that repeats on its
own but that is
a default loop structure however you may
need something
to repeat itself in a loop as well so
for that
we have loop structures basically we
have three kinds of loop structures
one is for loop the second is while loop
and then
third is do while loop we will look at
them one by one in their dedicated
videos
but before that let us see how it
exactly works so we make the entry to
the code then there is a condition based
on which
we take a decision if it is true then
the certain action which we have defined
will take place and then it will come
back and check the condition again
if it is still true then it will repeat
the action and this will go on and on
until this condition becomes false if it
becomes false
it will break out of that loop and
perform the action 2 which is written
after
the definition of loop after performing
that action
it will exit so in the next video we
will look at how exactly the first
control structure
which is for loop works we will see the
syntax
and we will see how it exactly works in
the coding so see you in the next video
so now let us begin with
the for loop this is the first loop
control structure which is very commonly
used in computer programming
first of all let us know about for loop
this is an entry controlled loop
what this means is the condition based
on which the task will be executed is
checked first
if it is true then only those statements
will be executed
and we use for loop when we know how
many times we need to run a loop
so let us see the syntax of for loop
first of all we write
4 then an open bracket then we
initialize some variable here
that variable will count how many times
the loop has to run
then we write the condition here that
condition can be anything
this condition mostly includes the
variable which we have initialized then
we update
the variable which we have initialized
we close the bracket
then we start a curly bracket we write
all the statements which you want to get
executed
then we write curly bracket let's see
how it is used now let's say
i tell you that you have to write your
name 10 times on the serial monitor
so what will you do serial dot print ln
let's say my name is
ashish so with your existing knowledge
you will take this line
you will write it 10 times and then you
will upload it you'll check on see that
monitor you can see it is getting
printed 10 times so now if i tell you
that you have to type it 100 times
so would you be willing to write it
hundred times i guess no
and some of you may tell that we can
write it in void loop instead
but writing that in void loop would mean
that it would keep printing ashish until
and unless you turn off your arduino
you won't be able to count if it has
printed 100 times you can sit there and
count that but that certainly doesn't
make any sense so for that a for loop
comes to a rescue
let's see how we use it we write for we
declare a variable
int i for example is equal to 0 and we
write a semicolon
then we write a condition here for
example how many times you wanted to run
let's say
i less than let's say we want to print
my name
10 times so let we will write 10 here
and we will update
the condition i plus plus okay we'll now
write serial dot
print ln ashish and now we'll see what
happens
right we can see the arduino printed my
name 10 times
on the screen one two three four five
six seven eight nine and ten
okay we can also add multiple statements
in this block
let's say we can write hello world
okay let's see what happens it will
write ashish hello world ashish hello
world yep as expected
it has repeated all the things 10 times
now what advantage do you have is
now if someone tells you that you have
to write it 20 times
instead of 10 times so instead of
copying pasting that code again
you can just alter 20 here now it has
written it 20 times
now for example i want to use this
declared integer i
in my code serial dot print and then
we can directly use this i here we can
also perform arithmetics on that
for example i can do i plus 2 i plus 5
i minus 5 i divided by 2 anything for
that matter
but please note that the scope of this
variable is just inside this block you
cannot use this declared variable
in other blocks even if you are using it
in some for loop or some
other function the scope of i will exist
only in this
block get my point let's see it will
print 0 to
19 okay
like 0 1 2 3 4 5
6 7 and 19. okay now let's
understand how it was working all right
so whenever we write a for loop
the first step which happens is
initialization this statement is
executed only once when the loop is
entered for the first time
and after this the second step is it
checks the condition
this statement is probably the most
important one it checks to verify
whether or not certain expression
evaluates to true if it is true then the
loop execution continues
then after that if the condition is true
it would move on to execute the
statements as the third step
after executing the statements it will
move on to
the fourth step which is updating the
variable it is typically used to
increment or decrement
some variable after the update the fifth
step is to check the condition
once again if that condition is true
again it will come back to execute the
statements once again then this step
continues again and again until this
condition becomes false the moment the
condition becomes false
it will come out of the loop and start
executing something which is written
after this loop now since you know this
let us understand the code which we
wrote earlier so now let us pay a closer
attention to everything which we have
written i've written for
end i is equal to 0 then a semicolon and
in the condition we have written
i less than 20 that means i
is acceptable till 19 okay
and then we have written i plus plus you
must be remembering that plus plus is
used to increment a variable
by one we have written serial.println
bracket ashish that means
when the value of i is 0 it will print
aashish once then it will print
hello world then it will print the value
of i itself which is 0 right now then
after executing this loop body
it will increment the value by 1 and the
value will become
1 okay when i is 1
it will check if i is less than 20 which
is true it will execute the body once
again
then the value of i will become 2 it is
still less than 20 then again it will
execute the body
so it will continue till 19 but after
executing it for the 19th
time and when the value becomes 20 this
condition will become false the moment
it becomes false it will not execute
these lines
and it will exit out of the loop in case
if we had written
less than equal to 20 then the condition
would have been true
but it would have actually printed it
for 21 times because it is starting from
zero
other thing which we can do is start it
from one instead of zero
it will be equivalent to this but
usually it is recommended that we start
from zero so after knowing this
really easy trick i'm really wondering
if you're wishing
that you knew this trick before when
your teacher gave your punishment so in
the next video we will look at
how to do nesting in for loops
see you in the next video so like we saw
next thing in fl's block we can do
nesting in for loops as well for example
if you want a printer pattern like this
a series of stars there are five columns
with five stars in each row let me just
comment it so that it doesn't create
problem in our code we can simply go
ahead
and write
and we'll write serial dot println and
we'll print five stars
right so let's see what happens when we
upload this
oops we forgot to add a double quote
so now again oh we forgot to write the
name of
variable and i let's see
so it printed a lot of stars but now
what if we want a pattern like this a
staircase type of pattern
let me comment that as well okay so how
will we do that
it's very simple we'll do nesting of for
loops
let's say for enti is equal to zero we
want five rows
okay so we will write five then i plus
plus then we will write another for loop
we will take another variable here and j
is equal to
zero and we'll write condition as j less
than equal to
i and then j plus plus okay and then
we'll write serial dot
print please don't will not write print
ln here because we don't want
it to print in next line so cl.print
and just a single star
and then once this for loops executes
we'll print a new line dot println so
let's see what happens here
okay we got that pattern now i'll
explain you how it worked actually
we took our first for loop we
initialized our integer i
as 0 and we gave a condition i less than
5 that
means it will not run when i exceeds 5
okay or becomes 5 then we wrote another
for loop and we took another variable j
is equal to 0
and j less than equal to i that means in
first iteration the value of
i was zero and the value of j was also
zero okay so here j less than equal to i
that means zero less than equal to zero
this is true and then
j plus plus so it will print a star okay
then the value of j will increase and it
will become
1 so now this statement will become
false because j is 1 and i is still 0
then it will
exit out of this loop and then it will
print a line
then that means after printing one star
it will print another line
okay and then it will come back to this
for loop now
the value of i is 1 is still less than
5 okay and then it will come into this
for loop
so now the value of j is 0 and the value
of i
is 1 okay so 0 is less than
equal to i it is true it will print
a star then again and j will become
1 this condition is still true because 1
is less than equal to
1 right so it will print another star
next to
the previous star so it will print 2
stars let us see in the serial monitor
right after printing this star it will
print this star
then the value of j will become 2 and
then
this condition will become false because
i was still 1
then it will exit out of that loop and
print another line
it will print another line here okay
then i will become
2 then it will go back in this loop and
it will execute
the loop three times 0 1 and 2.
similarly it will
go until and unless this condition also
becomes false
okay so i can understand it must be
really tricky right now
if you just go back and listen to what i
said once again you will understand that
and in case you don't understand you can
always drop a comment or message us
so in the next video we will look at
another kind of loop structure which is
known as a while loop see you in the
next video
in this video we will look at while loop
a while loop is also an entry controlled
loop an
entry control loop is a loop in which
the condition is checked
beforehand before executing the
statements which are written in the
loop body this is the same thing which i
told you for the for loop
all right but the difference between the
while loop and a for loop is
in for loop we know how many times we
want to run the loop but in while loop
we don't know how many times we want to
run the loop it is based
just on the condition if some condition
is true the while loop will
continue to run endlessly and the moment
the condition becomes false
the code control will move out of that
while loop
that condition can be based on some
variable or some external conditions
like some values given by the sensor
let's say we are making a robot
and we are using a distance sensor we
can use a while loop or to move forward
unless the distance is less than some
quantity
and we want to exit out of that by loop
as soon as the distance
gets lesser than that specified value so
that the robot can avoid the collision
from any obstacle in front of it right
there can be many more while loop uses
but we will begin with
the basics we will use our traditional
method of printing variables
on the serial monitor so let's see that
so we have our sketch here
let's use a while loop to print a table
of two
let's say we'll start with an integer
which we will use as a condition
int multiple is equal to one
let's start with 1 while multiple
is less than equal to 10
okay serial dot
print ln multiple
into two okay and let's increment the
multiple
all right let's see if we are able to
print the table of two
oops we forgot to write serial dot begin
always write serial dot begin
whenever you have to communicate with
the computer let's upload that again
right 2 4 6 8 10 12 until 20.
this is a table of two now let's print a
table of a complicated number
let's say 73 yep this is a table of 73
so now let me show you how a while loop
can run endlessly if the condition is
true
let us just make it true directly this
will become
an endless loop right now it will not
just print numbers from one to ten it it
will just print
them endlessly let's use the easy number
so that we can verify
it won't stop at all let's see
look at the speed it is printing all the
even numbers
can you see that let's have a look 2 4 6
8 10 12
14 16 as you know there's no upper limit
to the numbers so it will just go on
endlessly
until the limit of int expires
so i have another example to show you
how a statement controls
a while loop how it prevents the while
loop from running when it is false
and how it initiates the while loop when
it becomes true so in the white setup i
have written serial.begin 9600 to
initiate the communication and then i
have void loop
i have declared a static variable a test
variable which is
going to control our condition i have
defined it as static because
i don't want to reset the value of test
variable with each run uh if you have
any confusion regarding the static part
you can check
the dedicated video which we have made
to explain the static qualifier for a
data type
now while loop we have started the while
test condition greater than five
that means right now the test variable
is zero
as we have not initialized it so zero is
the default value so zero is greater
than 5
that means this is false so this
statement should not execute okay but
in the next line we have written
variable plus that means we want to
increment that variable
the variable value will become 1 and it
will print the value
of the test variable then we are waiting
for one second so that we can observe
the changes which are happening and then
again it will come here
it will see while test variable greater
than 5 that means it is still false
because test variable's value
is 1 right now and it is still false so
it will still not go into
this loop then it will become 3 then it
will become 4 then it will become 5
at 5 also this will not become true
because we have not used the equal to
sign
and when it becomes 6 this condition
will become true
and this will start printing let's see
that
right one two three four
five six and we are in the while loop
now
okay this while loop is repeating
endlessly because we have not specified
any exit condition
and please note while this is in while
loop these statements are not being
executed
the control of code is looping here only
since this loop is looping infinitely
we might want to use some break
conditions we will learn about
break and continue statements in coming
videos but in the next video
there is one more loop which is known as
a do while loop we'll learn about
do while loop in the next video we'll
take a look at the last
loop control structure which is the do
while loop the first thing which i want
to tell you about the do while loop is
it is
very very similar to the while loop it
works exactly like the while loop but
the only difference is
it executes at least once and that is
why it is the exit control loop
in exit control loop the statements are
first executed
and then the condition is checked while
in while loop first the condition was
checked if the condition was true then
the statements would execute
in this first the statement block will
execute and then it will check the
condition
if the condition is false it will exit
out of the loop and not execute those
statements further
and if the condition is true it will go
back and execute the statements once
again
if you look at the flow the first thing
which happens is it executes the
statement block then it checks the
condition
if it is true then it will go back
otherwise it will come out of that loop
a do while loop is also used when we
don't know how many times an action has
to be repeated but
we are sure that it should run at least
once in those cases
we use a do while loop a do while loop
is used where the statement has to
execute once otherwise we won't be able
to take decision for example we are
expecting a user to give us some input
and we want him to give
a positive integer as an input but for
example he is trying to give a negative
input so we can write a do while loop
while the user gives us the negative
input
keep telling him to give us the positive
input and the moment he gives us the
positive input
will break out of that loop okay so let
us see a basic example of using a
do-while loop
like we did earlier we printed a table
of two
we'll again print the table of two using
a do-while loop instead of a while loop
so let us see how we do that we have
initialized a variable known as multiple
and initialized it with
one okay we'll write cl dot begin to
start the communication with computer
so we'll write do then the bracket open
we'll write cl dot printenet multiple
into two then bracket close and
semicolon and then we will
increment the multiple and then we will
write while
multiple is less than equal to ten that
means this condition is true
until the multiple becomes 10 the moment
it becomes 11 this condition will become
false and this
statement will stop executing so we'll
get a table of 2 here
let us see what happens right so we got
a table of 2
2 4 6 8 and then so on till 20.
i have another example for do while loop
so that we can understand how exactly it
works
so in the white setup we have written cl
dot begin 9600 so that we can
communicate with the computer in while
loop i have initialized a static into
variable which is known as test variable
we have written do then we are writing
cl.println this
will print at least once because a do
while loop will execute the statements
at least once so ok we have written this
statement
and we have written a delay of 500
milliseconds so that we can observe what
is happening
otherwise you know serial monitor prints
things really fast so now we have
written while
test variable is greater than 5. while
the test variable is less than 5
this statement should not execute but it
will
execute at least once then we have
written test variable plus plus that
means we are incrementing the value of
text variable
here we are printing the value of test
variable and we have given a delay of
500 milliseconds so that we can
observe what is happening okay so now
when we open the serial monitor
what we will see is that this statement
will execute once then the test variable
will increment
okay and then the value of test
increment will print then it will go
back
into do while loop and print this
statement once again
because in do while loop it has to
execute once at least
then while it will check the condition
it is false then it will come back here
it will increment the variable and it
will
repeat till the test variable becomes
greater than 5
okay the moment it becomes greater than
5 so this do while loop will keep on
repeating
let's see how it happens let us upload
the code first
right this will get printed at least
once and this is printing again and
again
but now just see the loop control didn't
come out of this okay because this
condition is true now it will go back
again
and execute the statement these
statements are not being executed
because
it is still in do while loop so i hope
you understood this
do while loop so now i have a really
interesting illustration
which you can see on the screen to
explain the difference between a while
loop and a do while loop and i think it
is a really good example
to show the difference between the two
every one of you must have seen
the roadrunner show and we see this guy
was using the while loop
while this guy was using the two while
loop let's discuss in the comments
who was using these control loops in a
proper manner
if you remember i told you that we might
have to break out of the loops based on
certain conditions
like for example in an endless loop we
might need to do something
to stop that loop so the break keyword
is used to exit
from a loop by bypassing the normal loop
condition which we have specified
let's see how we do that so this is the
modified version
of the code which we used to print the
table of two okay
this is the regular while loop which is
running okay we are printing
a table of two here and we are
incrementing the multiple here
but now we have specified a break
condition okay
like if multiple is equal to five then
we will write breaking out of the loop
now
and we will break out of the loop by
just using this keyword
let's see what happens all right so we
printed it
till four two 4 6 and 8
and then it breaked out of loop although
it should have run till
10 it should have printed till 20. so if
i comment this break condition
and upload the code again so we got
the entire table so this is the basic
use of breaking out of the loop
now let's see if we are inside an
endless loop
let's say while true this is an endless
loop
we are writing serial dot println
endless loop okay
and we will increment the multiple
multiple
plus plus okay let's say
i want to exit after printing it 10
times
if multiple greater than
10. we'll just break out of it
let's see what happens
okay we forgot to close the white setup
bracket
right if we didn't use this break
statement
it would ultimately keep running
endlessly let's see that
quickly okay can you see that it's
printing endlessly
so i hope you understand we use a break
statement wherever we want to
break out of the loop so in the next
video we will see the continue keyword
and we will also compare the break and
continue keywords
like we saw in the break statement that
whenever we use it
code control instantly moves out of the
loop entirely discarding all the
remaining iterations of the loop
right like we were trying to print
numbers from 1 to 10 and when we used if
our variable is equal to 5 then break
out of the loop so it entirely skipped 6
7 8 9 10 but in some situations we might
want to use the remaining iterations
right so in that case the continue
keyword helps us with that
the continue statement skips the rest of
the current iteration of the loop and it
continues by checking the conditional
expression of the loop and proceeding
with the subsequent iterations
that means it won't skip the rest of the
iterations
let us see how it works so we have void
setup serial.begin 9600 as usual
then we are writing for loop to print
numbers from
0 to 10 right because we have
initialized i with 0 and we have used
less than equal to sign
so that means both the ranges are
inclusive so it will print 0 to 10 and
then we are incrementing the
variable now notice we have used if i is
equal to 5 then continue whenever we use
the continue keyword
it would straight away take us to the
condition pack and it would skip all the
statements which are written after that
so let us see what happens
so we see 0 1 2 3 4 5 is missing
and 6 7 8 9 and 10. so it skipped the
iteration in which i was equal to
5 right but it did not skip the rest of
the iteration if we had used the break
keyword it would have skipped the rest
of the iterations
it stopped at 4 only let me switch back
to continue here again and let me
explain the difference between
the break and continue statement let's
say we write a statement here
serial dot println end of our
for loop this is the end of our for loop
that means after
our for loop completes this statement
should print regardless of anything so
when we use continue
we'll see
the loop was going 0 1 2 3 4 and when
the value became 5
it jumped back to check the condition
okay
so in this way it had to skip this
statement it cannot
execute the statement right so when it
became six again then it will start
printing it again can you see that
and after completing the loop it came
and printed this line
when we use break
then the control will directly come here
whenever the break statement is
encountered
the code control goes directly out of
the loop can you see that after printing
it printed end of for loop so we may
have different situations to use
continue and break statement and we have
to make sure we use them correctly
so in the next video we will look at the
last keyword
which is return so see you in the next
video the
return keyboard the return keyword would
probably the easiest thing
to learn right now the only function of
the return keyword is to terminate the
function
no matter what it doesn't take any
conditions it doesn't take any
limitations or anything whenever the
code encounters the return keyword it
would just
terminate the function there are two
ways to use a return
we will be covering the first way to use
the return keyword we will cover the
second way in the coming videos
let us see how we use it in one manner
all right so i have this code written
here okay in the white loop
what i'm trying to do is i'm trying to
print line one line two line three and
line four
okay and then i have a for loop which
prints number from zero to
nine right let's see if it is working
properly
yes it is working as expected line one
nine two nine three nine four and zero
to nine
right so now i want that anything return
beyond this point
should not execute so i'll just write
return so we'll see what happens
it will just print line one and line two
it will go back here and execute this
lines only
anything written after return will not
execute
okay now you may want to remove it from
here
and use it here right let's see what
happens
it will just print zero because when the
value of i was zero
it printed zero then it encountered
return so it will just terminate this
function
and you see that it is not printing one
two three four five six seven eight nine
because return keyboard just terminates
the function
all right so now i will see you in the
next video so the next topic in our
course is
switch case like if statements switch
case controls the flow of programs by
allowing us to specify different code
that should be executed in various
conditions
in particular a switch statement
compares the value of a variable
to the value specified in the case
statements when a case statement is
found whose value
matches that of the variable then the
code in that case statement
is executed so let us see the syntax of
switch case first of all we write switch
then our open bracket then we write the
variable which has to be compared
when we close the bracket then we start
a curly bracket then we write
case space label 1 where label 1 is
the number which has to be compared to
the variable okay then we write
colon note that this is a colon not a
semicolon
okay then we write the statements all
the statements which we want to be
executed
when label1 is equal to the variable we
write those statements
in this block then we write break
semicolon
then we write case another label then
all the statements then we write break
we can write as many labels we want in
our code and the last statement which we
write is default
colon all the statements break when none
of the labels is true then the default
statement is executed
if we don't write default and none of
the statement is true then nothing will
happen
all right so now let us see the flow of
code in switch case here is the switch
conditional statement
then it will see case one if it is true
it will execute the statements written
in that block if it is false
it will check case 2. if it is true then
it will execute the
statement if it is false it will go to
case 3
okay and so on if none of these are true
it will
automatically jump to default and it
will execute the default statements
and after executing one of these
statements the flow will go on to the
statement which is written
after the switch let's see in the coding
right
and the white setup we have written
serial dot begin as usual then i'm
writing int
x is equal to 5 here x is the variable
which we want to be
compared okay then i'm writing switch
then x here because i want
x to be compared then i'm writing case 1
colon
serial dot println choice 1 break
similarly i've written 6 cases now can
you guess what statement will be printed
here since
x is equal to 5 my guess is choice 5
should be printed
because it is not equal to 1 it is not
equal to 2 it is not equal to 3 and so
on
ok so let us see what happens
right as expected it is printing choice
five now if i change
the value of x to let's say
one so now choice one will be printed
right now in case if we don't write
break here
the purpose of writing break here is
that we want to exit as soon as one
condition becomes true
let's say if we don't write break here
so it will continue to execute the
statements
since x is equal to 1 so now it should
print choice one choice two and choice
three
okay because there's another break after
choice three right choice one choice two
choice three
that's the purpose of break now let's
see one more example without break
let me use x is equal to 3
then it will start from here will not
use break here
it should print choice 3 choice 4
and choice 5.
right as expected now the important
thing which you need to notice is
the variable which we use here and the
labels which we use here
should be of int or character type if
you use float or if you use another
array type
it will just throw an error this switch
case is a really handy tool if you want
to write a lot of if else statements
instead of that you can just write case
1 case 2 case 3.
we can also specify ranges in case
statements and how we do that
let's say we want to take a range of 1
to 10. we'll write 1
we'll write three dots and then 10
okay then let's say 11 space
to 20 okay let's say
21 3 dots to 30
then we write 31 space you have to write
a space there okay
if you don't write a space you will get
an error so let's see these cases only
let me write break again okay so now let
us see
three what will happen it will write
choice 1
right now for example if i take 35
it should write choice 4
right so i guess you got an idea how
easy it is
right instead of writing if in else we
can use
switch case so i hope you understood
this topic so i'll see you in the next
video
so at this point we are in a position to
study about the two remaining data types
which are arrays and strings these two
data types are also very commonly used
in the projects which are made using
arduino
so in this video we will look at arrays
an array is a variable which can store
multiple values of same type
let's say we have a compartment of a
defined size which has multiple
containers in it
like this and those containers can store
same kind of
information let's see this by an example
to declare an array
we first write the type of data which we
are going to store in it
let's say int then we write the name of
that array
let's say my array okay and then we
write
a square bracket and we write a number
inside it
that number denotes the size of that
array
okay let's say five so when we write
this the compiler will create a space in
memory where you can store
those five integers okay now let's store
some values in this array to do that we
write equal to
then we write curly bracket and then we
will write five
values which we want to store in it
let's say one two three
four and five semicolon each value
is separated using a comma and each
value inside
an array is known as element of array
okay and each element has an address of
its own
that address is known as an array index
that index starts from zero okay let me
show that to you again
let's say we have an array of size 10 so
0 is the first index and 9
is the last index okay and the value
which is present at that
index is known as element let's see that
again encoding so this is the zeroth
element
and this is the fourth element okay
now let's try to access them how do we
access them serial dot
println my array
and then the value which we want to use
let's say
2 can you guess what will be printed
here tell me
0 1 and 2 so 3 should be printed
so 3 has been printed here for the first
time users it must be really confusing
that why it was started from 0. it is
very simple
because computer counts from 0. while
humans are in a habit of counting from 1
that's why we are finding it a little
confusing now let's
change the values which are present
inside this we'll take bigger and
complicated values
let's say 745 74
259 85 and 421
these are the random values which i have
chosen now if we try to print the second
element
it will print 259 because 259 is present
at
second index okay while zero is this one
first is this one second is this one
third is this one and fourth is
this one now we can alter these elements
as well
directly now let's say i want to change
the value which is present at
second index so we'll write my array
2 is equal to let's say
7 0 6 okay now the value of 259
will be replaced by 706 let's see
let's print that again now it should be
printing
706 right we can alter any value for
that matter
we can do our regular calculations on
array elements as well
let's say i have one variable in
my variable okay
now let's say i want to add some
elements and store that value in my
variable
i will write my array okay 0
plus my array 1
plus my array 2.
okay so now my variable will be holding
the sum of 7 45 74 and 249
not 249 706 because we have altered it
here
so let's try and print my variable you
can check on your calculators
if the answer is correct or not
so the sum of 745 74 and 706 is
15 25 1525 okay
similarly we can also do multiplication
subtraction division etcetera all the
operators can be used here
okay now we can also use elements of
these arrays
in for loops as well now let's use a for
loop to print all the elements
inside my array so how we will do that
for
int i is equal to 0
i less than 5
because size of my array is 5 then i
plus plus okay so now what will we do is
serial dot println my array then i
okay so it should print all the elements
which are present inside this array
so it is here
745 74 706
85 and 421 right you can compare them
here 745 74 706 because we updated the
value here
then we have 85 then we have 421 okay
now can you tell me what will we do if
you want to add 5
to all the elements of my array
okay so now let's say we'll write
for
i is equal to 0 i less than
5 then i plus plus will take my array
i is equal to
my array i write
plus 5
so now 5 will be added to all these
elements
so now 5 has been added so now let's
print this again
if we print this again so now we will
see
5 has been added to all the elements
let's see we are here it is printing
from here right
745 plus 5 is 750 74 plus 5 is 79
then 706 plus 5 is 7 11
85 plus 5 is 90 421 plus 5 is 426
okay this way we have added five to all
the elements now we can take
some of all the elements in the array as
well how will we do that
let's say int sum is equal to zero we
have initialized it by zero and for
int i is equal to zero
i less than five then i plus plus
okay what will we write is sum is equal
to
sum plus my array
i okay and after that we'll just print
sum right it is printing 2 0
5 6. so you can check on your
calculators if these values are
summing up to 2 0 5 6 but just make sure
you don't add these values you add
the new values the new value was 750
79 7 11 90 and 426
these were the new values these okay if
you add these values you will get
two zero five six so now we have learned
about how to use arrays
how to access the values in an array and
how to manipulate those values
what we saw till now in this video were
one-dimensional arrays
that means they just have one dimension
now there can be
multi-dimensional arrays as well like
two-dimensional arrays three-dimensional
arrays
like you can see here this pink box
is a two dimensional array
it has rows as well it has columns as
well
okay and then we have three dimensional
arrays as well
like it has depth as well it has rows it
has
columns and it has depth as well
multiple two dimensional arrays
make three dimensional arrays i just
give you one use case
where two dimensional arrays are used
for example we want to store
the pixel data image pixel data of a
black and white image
okay so we use two dimensional arrays
and let's say we have to store pixel uh
image pixel data
of a colored image which also has rgb
values
so we use a three dimensional array for
that in this video we will talk about
strings strings are basically a sequence
of characters
whatever we write or you can say
whatever messages which we write in our
code
are all strings let us see in the code
the easiest way to spot
strings is that you will find them
written inside double quotes
for example serial dot println
this is my string okay
this is my string is the message which
is going to be printed on the serial
monitor
but in itself this is my string is
a string okay now technically speaking a
string is nothing
but an array of characters and as we
have already studied
arrays it would be really easy for you
to understand so now to declare a string
we write char in the name of the string
which we want
for example i have written str 2 then as
we start
an array by a square bracket and a
number inside it we similarly write it
for string as well now example
i want to write ashish which has a s h i
s h
as characters in it okay and the number
of characters in ashish are
6. okay so what we will do is we'll
always take one additional number
to declare our string because an ending
to the string is denoted by a special
character which is known as a null
character
okay the compiler automatically takes
that into consideration when you write
a string or when you declare a character
array okay
in this case compiler will see okay the
person is trying to declare a character
array
which has these characters so it will
automatically add a null character at
the end so now when we print this line
it will print ash ish on the serial
monitor
okay another way is to declare
that null character explicitly for
example i will write
chart str3 then 7
is equal to ash ish and then
a null character this is the null
character which is denoted by a
backslash and a 0.
this way the compiler identifies that
okay
this string has come to an end okay so
it can differentiate between one or more
strings
without this character there will be
problems the compiler may think that
the another string which is coming after
this string is a part of that same
string there has to be some way
to differentiate between different
sentences okay so that's why we use
a null character which is backslash zero
another way to declare a string is
we write char str4 which is the name of
the string
and then we write square brackets
without a number inside it
the compiler is smart enough to
dynamically allot a number to this
bracket it will see okay the user has
written a string
which has ash ish inside that it will
automatically
allot a memory of seven to this string
because ashish has six characters in it
and including a null character it will
become seven okay we can also write
it like this str five seven ashish
simply in double quotes we don't have to
work this much
it is also okay if you take a larger
memory for a smaller string
but it is not okay to take a smaller
size string let's say five
for a longer okay now you will see it
will only print five characters
and then there is another way we will
talk about it shortly but right now let
me comment this out okay
we'll just upload this code and we will
see what we are getting
all right so this is my string then it
wrote ashish
for this ashish for this ashish
for this again
and it printed it till here okay we
forgot to write
serial dot print ln
for str
right it just skipped the last character
because we didn't give
necessary memory to it so according to
me
this is the best way to start writing
strings because obviously you do not
know how many characters your string
will contain and obviously you don't
want to spend that time
to count those characters right the
compiler is smart enough to calculate
the size
for you okay now there is another way
to write a string which is by using
a string class okay here
let me just comment this out this is
a string class we are up calling a
string class and we have named
str7 inside it and we have just written
whatever we want
inside that let's say ashish and when we
print this
it will straightaway print this ok
what's the benefit of using a class is
that it is a built-in class first of all
and it has a lot of functions inside it
and those functions can be like we can
compare a string
okay easily we're just writing string
name dot
equals if it is equals it will return
true and similarly there are many more
built-in functions inside the string
class for example i can tell you we can
print a character
at a particular sequence for example i
wrote str
and then serial dot println str can
at 0 so it will print a because
at 0 position a is present similarly
there are many more functions
like or starting with ending with and
there is a function like we can convert
the entire
string which is written in lowercase to
uppercase
and vice versa uppercase to lowercase
okay we can convert integers into string
we can convert
strings into integers okay so you may be
needing all these functions
while we perform our experiments strings
are used to contain
information messages or error messages
or any
logs okay we can store them inside
strings
and we can also display strings on our
serial monitor on the lcd display
or any kind of display okay we will now
understand
what are functions a function is a set
of statements that take inputs
and do some specific computation and
produces some output
the idea is to put some commonly or
repeatedly done tasks
together and make a function so that
instead of writing the same code again
and again for different inputs we can
call the function
we'll understand what i just said as we
progress in the video so before anything
else
let us first understand how to identify
a function
in the code whenever we see something
like this like void
name and then there are brackets then
there is a curly bracket then there are
some statements written
and then there is a curly bracket again
this is the basic structure
of a function okay where void is
the return type that means we start
writing a function by telling the
compiler the return type of that
function
where void means that function will not
return
anything now instead of white here we
can use
int boolean or float or anything for
that matter
whatever we want to return from the
function then we write
the name of the function we can name it
whatever we want like we saw
digital write or pin mode they were the
functions
and the name of that function was pin
mode and
digital write and then in the bracket we
write
parameters or some people call them
arguments
if there are no parameters or arguments
to the function we just keep this
bracket
empty or if there are parameters then we
specify those parameters how do we
specify the parameters we will see in
the next video okay
so i'll just basically tell you how do
we call a function now like this
in the blink example we called pin mode
function
to call a function we write the name of
the function along with the
parameters of that function in pin mode
led built in comma output was the
parameter of this function
right similarly we have called digital
right here and the parameters of that
digital right was
led built in comma i these are the two
parameters of digital write
so in the built-in libraries of arduino
pin mode and digital write must be
defined somewhere
that's why arduino is able to understand
what this exactly means
otherwise it won't be able to understand
right okay so it has made us
really easy that arduino guys have
defined this function somewhere
for us okay and we just have to call it
now let me tell you the benefits of
using the functions
the first biggest benefit of using the
function is it helps us to reduce the
code redundancy
what that means is for example we want
to do certain tasks so we may
write the statements again and again
again and again so that would make the
code unnecessarily bigger
so what we can do is we can make a
function and we just call that function
whenever we want to
do that task you will understand this
point better when we write our own
functions
then the functions make the code modular
and reusable
what that means is for example we are
making a robot there must be thousands
of lines to make the robot
go forward so what we can do is we can
make a function to make the robot go
forward and we can use that function
whenever
we want to make robot go forward and you
have written the code to make the robot
go forward so now you are trying to make
another robot
so you can use that same code for the
another robot as well
so that means it became modular and it
became reusable
then the other advantage of using
functions is edit provides abstraction
and aids teamwork for example you're
working in a team of four so one person
can write the code for robot to go
forward one person can write the code to
go backward
one person can write the code to move
right and left and one can
write the code to make the robot jump
okay so once these functions are written
so they can together be used as one code
all right so these are the advantages of
using a function
now in the next video we will learn how
to write our own functions
so you will understand these points in a
better manner so i'll see you in the
next video
so let us now create our very own
function we will create a customized
function
to blink the led okay so let's do this
after void loop we will write void
let's say the name of our function is my
blink function okay since there are no
parameters in this we will leave the
bracket empty now
so let us just cut this code from here
and paste this exactly like this in my
blink function
okay so now we have created
a customized blink function now let's
try to
call this function in void loop
right
this way we have called our function in
the void loop
all right so when we upload this code on
arduino you will see
exactly the same results all right so
let us see this
so let us compare both the codes with
the help of a simulator
all right so we had this code right this
is the same blink code
let's see how it is working right as
expected
the led at pin number 13 is blinking
right so now
let us replace the code which we have
just written
we will just take it as it is
right
so now let's start the simulation
so i hope you got my point about
creating our own functions
but now most of you must be wondering
what's the point of making this
right yeah i agree with you there is no
point of making a function for this
small task right but you will find it
useful
when you're writing really huge programs
or you want to customize this thing
i will show you a customization right
now all right
so now let's say you have more than one
leds which you want to blink in a row
okay so with your existing knowledge
what would you have done
you would have done it like this
so you would have repeated these lines
of codes
and just replaced the pin numbers here
right and then you would have declared
these pins as output right but now what
we can do is
we can make a customized function let us
do that
we are here
so let us now make a new function void
my
custom led right
now what we will do is we'll specify
a parameters in which we can tell the
compiler
led pin number so for that we will write
int pin number
okay so this function is going to accept
one parameter which is pin number right
so now let's do this
we have this code okay
so now instead of led built in we will
write
pin here okay so automatically whenever
we call this function
with the pin specified the compiler will
replace
this pin number with the specified pin
number okay
so let's do this
let us just confirm what pins we have
used
we have used nine seven and two
okay nine seven and two
so let us say int led one is equal to
nine
hint led two is equal to
seven and int led three
is equal to two right
so now we just have to declare all these
pins as output
led one okay
see
all right now we'll just replace them
like this since we have declared them as
output
now what will be do is we'll just take
this function
okay we'll write my custom led with pin
number
led one okay
then again we'll call this function with
led 2 right and again we'll call this
function
and we'll just pass led 3 this time
okay let's see if this compiles or not
yes it compiles successfully now let us
see the simulation of this code
right so we have this code here
let us start the simulation okay can you
see that
yep it's working perfectly
first the led one which is connected to
pin number nine is blinking
and then the led connected to pin number
seven is blinking then
the led connected to pin number two is
blinking so now let us see
one more time what exactly happened here
okay so with the pin mode we have
declared all the leds
led one two and three and i'm sure you
know how to do this we have done this
many times till now
okay so now we have created a function
void
my custom led with a parameter of pin
if you wanted more parameters here we'll
just write comma
and then end let's say
parameter 2 right
so this way we can specify endless
number of parameters in our functions
but since we don't need them we'll not
use them
okay then we have started to define
what this function will do which is it
will blink the led
okay which led will it blink the led
which we have passed as the parameter
okay because we have used pin here for
example if you had
declared number here instead of pin
then you would have used number here
instead of pin
got my point so now since we have
finished declaring our function
now we can use it successfully we'll
just take this function
and we will call it here with the
parameter so now we have called it for
the first time
with led1 now what will happen the
compiler will see
okay a function has been used which is
my custom led
with the parameter led1 so it will see
the value of led 1
which is declared as 9 okay so it will
call my custom led with 9
so the control will go to my custom led
with pin 9
and it will execute it with pin 9. once
it is done executing it will come back
it will see it has been called again
with another
parameter which is led 2 and the value
of led 2 is
7 this time so it will go back and
execute the function again
with the value of 7 all right so this is
the basic concept of
function customization okay so instead
of writing this code again and again
with changed
pin numbers we can just do this so i
think all of you can agree with what i'm
saying right now
right one more thing which needs
emphasis is
i've used void here like i told you we
use void whenever our function
is not returning us anything okay so by
the time you must have realized
void loop and void setup are two
functions of their own
they are the main functions which are
used by the compiler we have discussed
about this
earlier as well so now let us try to
make another kind of function
we'll open a new file
and we will start writing our function
first of all let's write serial.begin
this is the most crucial thing to start
communication with the computer
okay so now let us try to write a
function which would return us something
okay so let's say it will return us an
integer
so we'll write in earlier we wrote void
because we didn't want
it to return something to us if you're
not able to understand what returning
exactly means you will just see that in
a moment
so we'll write in let's say we want to
repeatedly calculate
sums of two numbers okay or let's say
sum of three numbers
so we'll write in sum
okay int a comma int
b comma int c
okay where a b and c are the three
numbers which we want to
take some off all right so now we will
write a curly bracket
and then we will write return a
plus b plus c okay
so whenever we call this function we'll
get a value of a
plus b plus c let's see how we get it in
white loop or void setup you can use
this function
anywhere you want let's say we'll use
this in
white loop okay let's say
we write int let's call it d
okay equals to sum
of 7 comma 8
comma 9 all right
and let's print
the value of d okay
so what should it print the sum of 7 8
and 9
which is 24 right we can use it again as
well
with the different set of values let's
say
we'll make another function int e is
equal to
sum 1
comma 2 comma 3
let's print this
we should get six right
so we're getting six 24 and 6.
it's repeating as we have used it in
while loop so you don't have to worry
about that
okay one thing which i want to tell you
is you can use this function like this
as well
serial dot println
directly in serial print sum
4 comma 5 comma 6 right
just make sure to close all the brackets
here we have closed the bracket of the
function
sum here we have closed the bracket of
serial.println
okay so this is called as calling
function inside a function
this is a very useful thing which we can
do in programming
but first of all let us see the result
if it is working or not
right so we are getting 15 here because
this function call here
is printing its value okay
now we can have more than one functions
in our code now let us declare another
function which would return
a boolean value let's say bool
um now we are making a function to check
if a person is tall or not based on the
height we
enter as the parameter all right so
let's name it
is tall okay
and int height
okay so this function's name is
install and the parameter is height
okay so we'll write if
height is greater than
100 return true
okay
or else return
false okay so this function will just
return true
if the entered height is greater than
100 and if it is less than 100 it will
say
false okay so now you will see how handy
it becomes
when you have to check height of
multiple people okay
so now let's call this in white loop
here we have while loop so let's say
serial dot print ln
is tall let's say
123 okay
now let's just comment out the print
statements so that they don't interfere
okay this function is still being used
in int d and e so you can say these
functions are working simultaneously
so we are just checking is tall or not
okay
let's see before i open the serial
pointer
you can guess your values
right it's printing one because it has
returned true
so now let us take another value which
is less than
100 serial dot println
is tall
20. so now we should get
false
so it would be printing 1 0 1 0 because
1 is for
install 123 and 0 is for
install 20. so let us see that
right 1 0 1 0 one zero one zero one zero
okay so if you have to check height of
multiple people
instead of writing this code again and
again for that specific height
you can just call this function and
enter the height so you can see how much
work you have reduced for yourself
right by writing the functions so this
was all about
writing a custom function there is no
upper level to the complexity of the
code which you write in your functions
you can write endless number of lines in
this function
okay like i told you in the introductory
video there may be a thousands of lines
which are responsible for making
robot go forward so in that case we can
write
void move
robot forward and we can just define our
parameters here
and we can just write our statements
like this right
and this is our function this block of
code won't make your robot go forward
i'm just giving you an example of how do
we write functions
okay so whenever we call move robot
forward
in void setup or in void loop so the
compiler will take this function
and it will execute that alright so in
the next video we will take a deeper
look at
some of the inbuilt functions which the
arduino makers have made for us
so see you in the next video now in this
video we will talk about
digital input and output what that means
is we'll take a closer look at
the functions which are made by the
arduino makers to read or write
any sort of digital data all right that
data can be some sort of input given by
external sensors and it can be some sort
of output data which is given by arduino
to other peripherals or components right
so there are basically two functions
which are digital read
and digital right so let's take a look
at digital right
digital right is a function which we
have seen multiple times
before as well so can you recall what it
used to do it used to
write a state of low or high to a
digital pin
so we'll see digitalwrite is a function
where digitalwrite is the name of that
function
all right and it has two parameters
which are pin
and state where pin is the pin number
which we want to manipulate
and the state is the value of either
high or low
where high means five volts and low
means zero volts okay
just make sure whenever we use digital
write we have to declare
that pin as output using pin mode all
right and i have told you this earlier
as well
right next we will see digital read
as the name suggests it will read the
state of that pin
okay so here digital read is the name of
the function which we are calling
and pin number is the parameter which we
pass into it to read the state of that
particular pin
okay if it is high or low so we will now
see a combined example of using digital
read and digital write and how will we
do that we will turn on one led
if a switch is pressed okay so let's see
how we do that
so i have the circuit diagram here in
which i have used a regular led
with a resistance in series which you
can see and here i have used
a push button switch so before we move
further let us first look at
what a push button switch looks like
from inside then only you will be able
to understand it in a better manner
so here is a push button switch all
right which has four terminals out of
which these two terminals are internally
connected and these two terminals are
internally connected as well
okay so when we press the switch these
two terminals
get interconnected and these two
terminals get interconnected when it is
not pressed these two are
not interconnected okay so let's get
back to our example
okay so the code is we have started with
int button is equal to seven
as we want to read the state of that
button on a digital pin number
seven all right in white setup i have
declared pin mode led built in which is
the led connected to pin number 13
as output and using pin mode we have
declared the button as
input because button will be telling its
state to the arduino hence it is used as
input
okay serial dot begin 9600 as usual then
in void loop i have written
serial.println
digital read and bracket button so here
i am asking it to print the state of the
button
either it is pressed or not in the
circuit which we have used we will get
one on pressing the switch and we will
get zero when we do not press the switch
all right so let us see that works when
i'm pressing the switch
i'm getting one here when i'm releasing
the switch i'm getting zero here
look at the serial monitor here right
now i'm not pressing it so it's saying
zero
when i'm pressing it it's saying one
okay so most of you must have also
noticed the led which is connected on
pin number 13.
when i'm pressing the switch the led is
getting turned on and when i'm releasing
the switch
oops it's not getting turned off why
we'll see that in the moment probably
there is some error in the
code i've done this intentionally so
that you can pay attention to that
okay so here i have written if digital
read button is equal to high
then digital write led built in to high
when i press the switch
write a high state on pin number 13 but
i have not written what to do
if the button is not pressed so let us
do that now we will write
else digital right
led built in low
okay so now let us start this again
there was an error the closing bracket
to void loop was missing
so let us start it again all right
so when i press it the led turns on and
when i release it
the led turns off okay so you guys must
be wondering
what's the point of doing this we can
use a simple series connection
and we can turn on the led why are we
using arduino in that i absolutely agree
with you
you can do that very easily using a
series connection but what you have
learned here is
you have learned how to use the
functions like digital read and digital
write
you will be able to implement this
learning in further projects
the experiments which you do all right
so now let me just quickly explain you
the circuit which we have made here as
most of you must be facing
difficulty in that all right so here is
the switch
i showed you the diagram previously
right so these two terminals are
interconnected
automatically when i press the switch
this terminal will get connected to this
terminal
okay so i have taken a wire and
connected one terminal
to 5 volts okay and then i have taken a
resistor
and i have connected it to ground so
here we have made a series connection of
a switch and a resistor
like this and from this point as all
these points are interconnected we can
connect them anywhere
so at this point we're reading the
voltage which is present between
this and this point okay so as we want
to read the state we have connected it
to the pin number seven so when we press
the switch this
line will get connected to this line and
entire 5 volts will drop across
this resistance okay so hence the
arduino will read it as
high state and when the switch is
released this point will be connected to
ground via resistor so it will be read
as low
okay so i hope you understood the basic
idea
let me try to clarify it even more
so this is the equivalent circuit of the
circuit which you saw earlier
okay you can consider arduino's 5v pin
connected to
this switch this is a push button switch
right similarly these terminals are
connected
and when we press the switch these two
terminals will get interconnected
okay so in the series we have used a
resistance and we have connected one
point of that resistor
to ground okay and we are trying to read
voltage from this point can you see that
we have connected this point
to arduino's pin number seven all right
so this way we are able to read the
state of a switch
now what advantages can you have after
reading a state of a switch
you can trigger multiple actions like
running a motor
or sending some message right you can do
anything for that matter
so now you have learned about digital
input and output and in the next video
we'll look at other functions like
analog read and analog write
so see you in the next video in the
digital input output video we saw that
we can use a function called as digital
read to read the state of a pin
if it is high or if it is low that means
we can just read the binary situation
if it is on or either of that's all but
while making our projects
we may have situations in which we have
to read
not just those discrete values we may
also have to read the continuous
voltages so for that
we have analog read this function can be
used only on
the analog pins which are numbered a0 to
a5 right before seeing how it works
we'll have a basic idea of
analog information in the environment so
just look at this flowchart we have
the real world which is our environment
at the top we have some sensor
which is converting that physical
parameter into an analog signal
that physical parameter can be
temperature some distance
or humidity or anything for that matter
that analog signal
is then converted into digital signals
by
an analog to digital converter arduino
has a built-in
10 bit adc the short for analog to
digital converter is
adc so whenever i say adc you can
understand that i am saying analog to
digital converter so that digital signal
which is converted from
analog signal that is used by arduino to
make decisions
our arduino board is capable of
measuring voltage between 0 to
5 volts and this is the conversion scale
what i mean by that is since the
resolution
of adc on the arduino board is 10 bits
it can hold up to 1023 values okay
so if we compare that if the arduino
reads 0 volts so the corresponding adc
value will be
0 and if it reads 5 volts the
corresponding adc value will be 1023
and we can use unitary method to find
out values in between for
example you can tell me what will 3.3
volts
mean i hope i don't have to explain you
the unitary method right
this is the scale if zero volt means
zero and five volt means one zero two
three so one volt will mean
one zero two three divided by five so if
you know the value of one volt you can
find out value of
any voltage so now many of you must be
wondering from where this value of one
zero two three came from so i'll quickly
explain it to you we have a cupboard
here
which contains ten boxes and each box
can contain a value of either zero or
either
one okay so this is the cupboard and
these are the
boxes individual boxes to find the value
of the cupboard we take the value of
each box and we multiply it with the
multiplier the multiplier is this 2 to
the power 0 is
1 2 to the power 1 is 2 2 to the power 2
is
4 and similarly 2 to the power 9 is
512. so when we have values of all the
boxes
we take sum of all those values and we
get the value of that
entire cupboard so the maximum value
which can be held by a cupboard in which
all the boxes contain a value of one
will be one zero two three how this box
will evaluate to one
why because two to the power zero is one
and one multiplied by
1 is 1 okay so now the 2 to the power 1
is
2 and we multiply 1 by this so we get 2.
so we will be summing
all the values from here to here like 5
12 256
128 64 32 16
8 4 2 and 1 when you sum all these
values you will get 1 0 2 3 you can try
it on your calculator right now
so now let's take a look at analog read
function this function is simply used by
calling analog read
with the parameter of pin number where
pin number is a0 to
a5 so whenever you call this analog read
function it will return you the value at
red on that
pin so let's see how we use that so now
i have used
two one kilo ohm resistances in series
can you see that so now i have connected
it to
5 volts this point is connected to 5
volts and this point is
connected to ground so you can imagine a
series circuit
so now i want to read voltage across
this resistance since both the
resistances are equal
the 5 volt will split equally on both
the resistances
so we should be getting 2.5 volts let us
see that so in the code we have written
serial.begin
to start communication with the computer
and then we have written serial.println
bracket analog read a0 that means i want
to read the voltage
which is given at a0 so let's try this
code so we are getting
511 which is nearly 2.5 volts
we saw in that scale right so let's
change the resistance and see what value
do we get now
let's make this value as 2 kilo ohms
right so we got a change in value more
the value of resistance more the voltage
will drop across it
we can see the value of voltage across
this resistance is increasing if we make
it too high
it will increase it will also change if
we change the value of this resistance
let's say we make it 10. so now
the voltage across this resistance will
drop and hence we get a lower value
now let's see this with a light
dependent resistor this is a special
kind of resistance which changes
its resistance when light falls on it in
most of the light dependent resistance
the resistance will decrease
if the light on it increases okay so
let's try this
replace this resistance with
a light dependent resistor okay we'll
connect this in series
we'll take it here all right and we take
this wire now you see
this bar will represent the amount of
light falling on it right i can control
it like this
so right now here it is total darkness
and here it is very bright okay so when
it is dark the resistance of this
component is very high
okay so the voltage which drops across
this resistance will be very low
you can see the value is very low right
as soon as i increase the light on it
you will see the value in the serial
pointer is increasing
can you see that because the resistance
of this component is getting lower and
and more voltage is dropping across the
resistance
okay now this is the principle of analog
read now you can see how we can read the
value of analog sensors using
analog read all right so in the next
video we will look at the another
function which is known as
analog right so see you in the next
video in this video we'll take a look at
analog write function which is another
important built-in function
of arduino all right so to begin with
analog write i would firstly like to
tell you that it has no relation with
the analog pins or analog read function
it is absolutely a different thing what
exactly it is we will see
shortly so to use analog write function
we write analog write
bracket pin number on which we want to
use analog write
and then we specify a value which ranges
from 0 to 255.
we close the bracket and use a semicolon
right
the important thing which we need to
note is the pin numbers which we can use
here
are specific which are pin number 3 5
6 9 10 and 11 only okay
while all of these pins except pin
number five and six
support a frequency of 490 hertz and pin
number five and six support a frequency
of
980hz we don't need to worry about this
frequency right now
i'll explain as we progress so before we
dig deeper into this
we need to understand a few terms like
pwm
pulse width and frequency and even
before that we need to know what exactly
this analog write function does
the analog write function generates a
square wave of a specified
duty cycle on that specified pin the
major purpose of using analog write is
to control the brightness of led or to
control the speed of a motor
right the first thing which we need to
see now is a square wave what a square
wave is on the screen you can see
a square wave is coming this is a square
wave okay
although this is a varying square wave
now a square wave is nothing
but a signal which has only two discrete
values either on
or off as you can see here it is on
and here it is off and the time for
which it is on
and off is varying you can see here
right i can understand it must be
little difficult to comprehend but
please stick with me okay so the next
term is
pulse width the amount of time for which
a signal is on
is known as pulse width for example in
this wave
this is the pulse width denoted by this
arrow in this portion
this is the pulse width noted by this
arrow
all right the next term is duty cycle
duty cycle is the fraction of period for
which the signal was
on right so we have five sections here
with zero percent duty cycle twenty five
percent due to cycle fifty percent duty
cycle seventy five percent duty cycle
and hundred percent duty cycle okay so
in this section
the voltage for entire time was zero
okay
so that means the duty cycle is zero
percent
in this section we have about one fourth
of the time
as on you can see that right for the one
fourth time it is on
and three fourth time it is off so that
means the duty cycle is
25 in this section we have about
half of the time as on time and half of
the time as of
time so here the duty cycle is 50
similarly here the on time is 3 4
hence the duty cycle is 75 and here
for the entire duration of time the
voltage was on hence
the duty cycle was 100 okay now
if we look in terms of arduino when we
call analog write
with a value of 0 it will give us 0
percent duty cycle
that means the signal will be off for
the whole time
if you write analog write 64 then it
will give us a duty cycle of 25 percent
if you write 191 it will give a value of
75 percent and 255 will give us a duty
cycle of 100
okay so now to summarize pulse width
modulation
or pwm is a technique for getting analog
results
with digital means digital control is
used to create a square wave which is a
signal
switch between on and off all right and
this
on and off cycle takes place really fast
and this on off pattern can simulate
voltages in between
full on and full off by changing the
portion of the time the signal spends
on versus the time that signal spins off
all right so next thing which we need to
look at
is the pwm frequency okay
let's see this is a wave which has a
duty cycle of
50 that means half of the time the
signal is on
and half of the time signal is off
changing the frequency of the signal
will not change the duty cycle of the
signal okay so let's say
we have a signal of 50 duty cycle here
and if we make the frequency to 400
so the waves will become closer that
means now it will turn
on two times and turn off two times
right you can see here
on and off earlier it was on one time
and off one time
okay but you see the duty cycle is still
50 you're getting my point so you see
the duty cycle of the signal has not
changed
because it was still on for the half of
the time and off for half of the time
even if i make it 600 it is still on for
the half of the time
and off for half of the time okay so i
hope it was clear to you and if in case
it was not clear to you
we'll take an example and blink the led
and change the brightness of the led
all right and we will also monitor it
along with a digital oscilloscope an
oscilloscope
is nothing but it is a device which is
used to analyze the signals okay so
let's see that so here what we have done
is we have taken an led
on pin number 10 and correspondingly we
have connected these wires to an
oscilloscope to see the signal so let us
see the
code first so you must have noticed that
we have not written anything in void
setup
and we don't have to use pin mode
whenever we want to use analog write
function
okay so now in void loop i have written
analog write
pin number 10 and a value of 50
okay and then i have given a delay of
one second then analog write 10 with the
value of 100 then 150 then 200 and 255
here we will get a duty cycle of 100
okay so now let's see how it looks like
pay attention to the wave which is
coming on the oscilloscope
and also note the brightness of this led
i'm starting the simulation
let's see can you see that the
brightness of led
is increasing gradually as the code
progresses and it gets backs to 50
and then it again increases also note
the pulses which are coming in the
oscilloscope so now we will see an
example in which we are changing the
brightness of led in steps of
five we will also look at the pwm wave
simultaneous
let's look at the code first we have
defined an led pin which is connected on
pin number ten in white setup we don't
have to do anything
in void loop we have written four which
is a for loop and we have defined a fade
value
in fade value is equal to 0 and you have
to do this till
the fade value is less than or equal to
255 okay
and then we are incrementing the value
of fade value by
5. this is an another compound operator
you can say it is similar to writing
fade value is equal to fade
value plus 5 all right
so now we have written analog write and
we have written led pin here which is
pin number 10
with the fade value okay
so how it will go it will write zero
here then after the delay of 30
milliseconds it will write five year
then after a delay of 30 milliseconds it
will write 10 here then 15 and 20
and 25 and so on till 255. once this
value
becomes 260 you know in the last
iteration the value will become 260
so this condition will become false and
it will exit this for loop and come
inside
this for loop in this for loop we have
used fade value starting from 255
and we have written a condition fade
value greater than equal to zero
that means you have to do this till the
value is greater than
or equal to zero okay then we have to
use fade value minus equal to five
and this is similar to writing yes you
guys did right it is similar to writing
okay so now it will start
at 255. after a delay of 30 milliseconds
it will write 250 and 245 then 240
and 235 and so on till 0. in the last
iteration
when the value is 0 the value will
become -5 and the condition will become
false so this loop will exit and it will
come back
into this for loop and this will repeat
endlessly till we turn off the arduino
let's start the simulation note the
brightness of the led and note the
signal which is coming in the
oscilloscope
let's see okay
it's interesting right the brightness of
leds increasing
from 0 to 55 and the pulse width is
changing when it is 0
you can see it is entirely off and when
the duty cycle becomes 100 it becomes
entirely on
the pulse width is changing here so i
hope you have understood this really
well
the last topic which we need to learn
about before starting our experiments
is the arduino libraries so libraries
are a collection of code that makes it
easier for you
to connect to a sensor display or a
module for example
there is a built-in library to control a
liquid crystal display
that library makes it easier for us to
talk to that display
right for example you can see that
library will control what character will
come at what position
apart from this library there are many
more libraries which are available for
download on internet
and there are also built-in libraries
for example
the built-in libraries are these
libraries which are already present in
arduino id i'll just name a few like ap
rom
is used to read and write elements from
the permanent storage
a gsm library is used to connect gsm or
gprs network with the gsm shield
the liquid crystal library which you
just saw controls the liquid crystal
display which is used for reading and
writing data on
sd cards a server library will be used
to control server motors similarly there
are many more libraries which are
already there on
arduino the code which is written inside
those libraries can be written by
someone else
or you can write the code on your own as
well once we have the library in our
arduino
id it's very simple to use that library
i'll just show you how
so this is our code let's say we have to
use liquid crystal library so we will
write hash
include liquid crystal dot
h okay whenever we use this library
we'll be able to use the functions which
are written inside the liquid crystal
library
okay similarly if we have to include
another library for sd cards we'll write
sd dot
h okay this will include the sd library
in our code
we'll be able to use all the functions
which are written in sd library
i would also like to tell you that the
functions which we were using like
digital write
were also declared in some library i
will just show you
how it was written so there's a built-in
code which is written inside
wiring underscore digital dot c which is
located at this location
see program files arduino hardware
arduino avr course
arduino and then finally the file now if
we see the declaration of
digitalwrite we will see that this is
how a digital write function is declared
in that library
okay you just see that void digitalwrite
pin number and value okay where pin is
the pin number and value is high or low
it accepts two arguments right we sorted
while calling this function
so this is how the digital write is
called we'll not get into
details of this function as it may be
very complicated for you to understand
okay similarly digital read has been
declared here this is a declaration of
digital read
similarly pin mode is also declared
right so i hope you were clear with
libraries
and i hope you understand how using
libraries saves a lot of our time
okay so in the next video we will see
how to add
additional libraries in our arduino ide
so see you in the
next video so now let's see how do we
install external libraries in our
arduino ide there are basically two
methods
one is through the library manager and
one is through
adding external zip files okay let's
look at
the library manager first we will go to
sketch
include libraries then manage libraries
it will open the library manager this is
the library manager
it will update all the libraries which
are already there
in their database and it will show us
the list of available libraries for us
you can see there are a lot of libraries
already there
right these are all the libraries which
are present
in their database right now so let's say
we need a library for dht 11
which is a sensor which captures
temperature and humidity of our
environment
so we will write dht11 here and it will
search all the libraries
which are available for dht 11 by
different authors
so let's say this is a very reliable
library by adafruit
which i've already installed okay so
just in case you have not installed it
already you will get
install here you can select the version
here which version you want to install
usually this is the latest one and then
you just click on install
and it will install the library in your
id okay
once it is installed we can use it in a
regular manner
hash include
dht dot h
okay if this dht library was not
installed in my id
it would not appear in this orange color
okay
let's take an arbitrary name include
ashish dot
h since there is no library named ashi
so this ashish is not coming in
orange color although this is not a very
hard and fast rule you might not get
orange color in some libraries but it is
a really
good indication that you're working in a
right direction
okay so now let us look at the other way
which is adding them
manually let's say again we want a
library
for our dht11 sensor we will write dht
11 library
for arduino usually
libraries are available on github you
may also find zip files on some other
websites
but github is usually preferred as you
would get the latest version of the
library from there so again adafruit has
hosted their library on github
so let's click on that and then we'll go
to clone or download
we'll click download zip
and it will start downloading it you
have to see where you have downloaded it
you have to go to sketch include library
then add
dot zip library in my case i downloaded
it
in my h drive so it is here we'll click
on this
and just click on open in my case it was
already installed so it gave me a
warning a library name dht sensor
library master already exists
okay but in your case it will say the
library has been successfully installed
so these are the basic two ways in which
we add libraries
at this point i can really say that you
have reached a milestone
and you are in a position to dig deeper
as you have so many tools under your
belt now
we have covered the foundations of
electronics then we covered
what is an arduino board and then we
discussed what is inside arduino
we covered the difference between the
microcontroller and microprocessor
then we saw the arduino ide how it works
and how we use it
we also saw an online simulator which
can be used if someone doesn't have an
arduino right now
then we saw how to use a breadboard then
some topics like
input output analog digital etc and then
we started
arduino programming and i tried to cover
all the essential topics which are
required
for you to start your own projects from
this point you can try making
various led patterns you can try to work
with
a seven segment display which can be
used to display different digits on it
then you can try to interface sensors
like ultrasonic sensor
or ir sensor and try to read their
values using the built-in functions
which we have studied already
then you can try to control the motion
and speed of a dc motor
then i recommend you to try using a
servo motor after this
you will be in a position to make robots
like a line falling reward
a robot which is capable of following
light lines over a dark background
or vice versa
you can also make obstacle of winning
robots
then you can make remote control cars
like this and once you get comfortable
with this
you can also make complicated robots
like a hexa port
like this which has several servo motors
used in it
right which is moving forward you can
also check out some posts at my
instagram
ashish underscore things and check out
some of my other projects as well
so i hope that you found this course
really useful to begin your journey with
arduino
thank you so much for your time and have
a nice day ahead